REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEETO WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY IN TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WHO MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING CENTER
HERE'S A SOCIAL DISTANCING IT
FACED DIFFERENT GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS IN THE NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS. TO LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE GOING ARE
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME MEMBERS
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY
THREE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL BE HERE IN
THE HEARING ONE SENATOR IS
PROTESTING REMOTELY CENTER
STERN. IS NOT IN HIS OFFICE
JUST SOCIAL IDENTIFIED HIMSELF-
WHEN HE ARRIVES THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
THERE. ARE ALSO PROTESTING
REMOTELY FURTHER OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN LUMBINI ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I S. IT EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO SPEAK. HE WAS
TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT USED TO
RAISE THE HAND FEATURE ON THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND YOU. WE
SELECT AND MOVED YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. RT PERSONNEL PUT YOU
BACK ON YOU WHEN YOU'RE DONE.
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE. YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN. YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE. NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL NOW SIT OUT TODAY'S.
PARTICIPATE NUMBER IS
844-291-4185 IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS THREE THREE EIGHT OH FOUR.
SIX SEVEN FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE ISTOM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE OR-
COMMITTEE WEBSITE PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US. TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY INTO AVOID
ACOUSTIC. FEEDBACK YOU TOO MUST
MEET YOUR DEVICE WHEN YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE IS IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM AS BEST AS I CAN.
DURING THE HEARING YES IT'S
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL.
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE. MEETING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BE HEARD. AFTER
ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED FOR BOTH PART A AND
PART B. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE. TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS CONDUCTOR
HEARING CENTER. IN AS CLOSE TO
THE SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE. ADJUSTING
TO NEW. USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL OF PATIENTS SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. LASTLY FOR ANY.FOR
EVERYONE PHYSICALLY PRESENT
HERE TODAY PLEASE KEEP YOUR
MASK ON. COVERING YOUR NOSE AND
MOUTH AT ALL TIMES. OKAY WE-
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS TO
START A QUORUM SO WE WILL-
PROCEED AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
FROM ANNA. THEN I WILL HAVE MR
HECKER OF. CALL THE ROLL WHEN
AT THAT TIME IS UP. ALL RIGHT
SO LET'S BEGIN WITH A PRIVATE
PARTNER PART EIGHT BASE WE'RE
TAKING ALTHOUGH IT'S AT THE END
OF TODAY'S HEARING WILL SKIP
THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS ON ISSUES
ONE IN FOUR WILL BEGIN WITH A
DISCUSSION ITEMS IN PART A THIS
IS THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. ISSUE NUMBER- FIVE.
B. C. MY WITNESSES. WE HAVE
MISTER. CASH WHO'S PRESENTING
FIRST LET ME SEE I SHOULD KNOW
THAT. THE C. C. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT YOUR PROPOSAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND COMMISSIONERS MY NAME
IS TRUE VOTE AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION- BRIAN CASH
IS ALSO WITH US THIS MORNING AS
FINANCING. I KNOW YOU HAVE A
FULL PLATE WILL BE VERY BRIEF
WE'RE SPEAKING WITH THROUGH
THIS ITEM TO INTERACT WITH
HOURS ANNUALLY FOR THREE YEARS
AND THIS IS TO BE USED FOR
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION
SERVICES TO SUPPORT A DATABASE
WE HAVE STILL. HAVE SUPPORT THE
SCHOOL ENERGY EFFICIENCY
STIMULUS PROGRAM WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED BY AB EIGHT FORTY
ONE WE ARE CURRENTLY BUILDING
THIS DATABASE IN HOUSE WITH
EXISTING RESOURCES BUT WE NEED
TO SUGGEST THIS ADDITIONAL
REQUESTED FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THE ON GOING- FUNCTIONALITY AND
MAINTENANCE OF THE DATABASE
ONCE IT'S BUILT. THIS WAS NOT
PART OF THE GEN TEN BUDGET
BECAUSE WE'RE STILL WORKING ON
OUR- ST ONE BUSINESS ANALYSIS
AT THE TIME THAT THE- MATTER
WAS SUBMITTED. TO PROPAGANDA
BUDGET THANK YOU. CALIO CAN
HEAR FROM YOU ONE THE-
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE SCHOOL
RE OPENING VENTILATION AND
ENERGY ELECTRIC ENERGY
EFFICIENCY VERIFICATION REPAIR
PROGRAM. WAS WELL TO SCHOOL NON
COMPLIANT PLUMBING FIXTURE AND
APPLIANCE PROGRAM. THANK GOD I
DIDN'T FOCUS ON EDUCATION. I
WOULD REALLY HAVE A CHALLENGE
THEIR ON THEIR UNIQUE
PARTICULARLY UNIQUE NAMING OF
PROGRAMS. GOOD MORNING MR SURE
MEMBERS ROSS BROWN WITH THE L.
A- WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL WE THINK
IT'S A REASONABLE REQUEST- TO
IMPLEMENT THE- THE LEGISLATION
THAT WAS ADOPTED LAST YEAR.
OKAY M. N. ANYTHING TO ADD ON
THE MAINTENANCE OF THE PROGRAM
FOR THE MAINTENANCE OF THE-
THAT THE SEEDS PROGRAM I THINK
THAT STATE. THE CATCH THE
PROBLEM HERE RIGHT. I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD
THIS KIND OF THE REQUEST FOR
THE MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS
OF THE SYSTEM WAS NOT PART OF
THE BUDGET REQUESTS THAT WAS
PART OF IT YOU CAN GOVERNOR
JANUARY BUDGET AS- DIRECTOR
BOEING AND MENTIONS AND SO. WE
DO THINK OF THAT THAT KIND OF
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW IT IS A
REASONABLE REQUEST TO KIND OF
CONTINUE TO THE MAINTENANCE
OVER THE LIFE OF THE PROGRAM.
OKAY CAN YOU THINK OF FOR- AB
EIGHT FOUR ONE. THE. TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR THE NEXT THREE FISCAL YEARS
IT SEEMS REASONABLE. YES WE DO
FINANCE YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO
ADD HERE. FIVE M. ELEVEN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET REQUEST ALSO HAD-
CONTINUES FOR CREATION
LANGUAGE- TAKE A TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR THE AB EIGHT FOUR
ONE PROGRAM IF THAT WAS NOT TO
GO FORTH WOULD BE REQUESTING
EXTENDED ENCUMBRANCE
IMPLICATION FOR THIS- SEATS
FUNDING. OKAY AND M. DOES
ANYBODY WANT TO VENTURE INTO IF
WE ACTUALLY FUNDED THESE
PROGRAMS WHAT SORT OF OUTCOMES
COULD WE HAVE YOU KNOW WE- WE
HEAR WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION HERE ABOUT-
COVERED ENTITIES WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT CAP AND TRADE
HERE IN A MINUTE BUT WE KNOW
OUR- BUILDINGS IN THEIR PUBLIC
BUILDINGS ARE. A BIG WASTE FOR
CARBON EMISSIONS AND
INEFFICIENCIES. DR BOHAN. YEAH
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION- CHAIR
WE HAVE DONE A LOT ABOUT REACH
ON THIS TOPIC WHICH- HOSTED A
COUPLE WORKSHOPS TO GET INPUT
FROM OF COURSE THE SCHOOLS THAT
WOULD BE IMPACTED- COULD BE
RECEIVING FUNDS BUT ALSO FROM-
FROM LABOR FROM ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY FROM A VARIETY OF.
SOURCES AND SO YES WE THINK
THAT THE VENTILATION- WILL WILL
IMPROVE CERTAINLY CERTAINLY
VENTILATION AND INVITED COVE
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT IN ITS OWN
RIGHT BUT ALSO IN MANY CASES.
WILL IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY OF
THE UNITS THAT PROVIDE
VENTILATION. A LOT OF THESE
UNITS ARE OLD AND THE FIRST
TRANCHE OF FUNDING IS FOCUSED
ON- TAKING A LOOK AT THE AT THE
UNITS THAT ARE INSTALLED IN
SCHOOLS PREFER WORKING
PROPERLY. BRING THEM UP TO
SPEED IF NEED BE AND THEN WILL
BE LOOKING AT ADDITIONAL
CRUSHES THE FUNDING GOING
FORWARD AND THEN THE PLUMBING-
WATER IS THE CONSUMPTION THE
DELIVERY CONSUMPTION AND
TREATMENT OF WATER. ON THE
BACKEND. IS AMONG THE LARGEST
SOURCE OF ENERGY CONSUMPTION IN
CALIFORNIA SO TO THE EXTENT WE
REDUCE THAT TWO FIXING LEAKY
PIPES WE WILL ALSO CONTRIBUTE
TO REDUCED. ENERGY CONSUMPTION.
THANK YOU A CENTER DOLLY. HOW
MUCH OF THE- HAS THE CC ALREADY
TO THREE TO THE SEED SYSTEM
DEVELOPMENT IN TOMORROW'S FUNDS
BEING READ DIRECTED FROM. GOOD
QUESTION WE HAVE- DIRECTED
FUNDS FOR THIS EFFORT TO GET
THE- IN TO GET TO THE SYSTEM
BUILT IN UP AND RUNNING BECAUSE
WORK WE'RE ANTICIPATING WE WILL
ADOPT GUIDELINES AND OUR JUNE
BUSINESS MEETING- I WILL SEE IF
I AM I HAVE COLLEAGUES ON THE
PHONE WHO ARE I AM CONNECTED TO
BY. TEXT AND I WILL SEE IF I
CAN GET A TEXT TO GIVE YOU I
WANT TO GIVE YOU THE WRONG
SOURCE OF FUNDS- THAT WE'VE
BEEN UTILIZING AT THIS POINT
OUR PRINCIPAL FUNDING ACCOUNT
IS THE ENERGY RESOURCES PROGRAM
ACCOUNT- BUT- BUT I DON'T WANT
TO. SAY FOR CERTAIN THAT SPEND
THE SOURCE UNTIL I UNTIL I FIND
OUT FOR SURE. MISLEAD YOU HAVE
SOMETHING TO ADD. I'M SORRY
JUST. TO MAKE SURE THAT I WAS.
TO US FOR DIRECT ABOUT HAND- I
AM NATALIE LEE AND THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR RENEWABLE ENERGY.
AT THE ENERGY COMMISSION AND-
THIS PROGRAM IS HOUSED IN MY
DIVISION. AND I CAN JUST SPEAK
QUICKLY. THAT THE- DATABASE TO
DATE. HAS BEEN DEVELOPED WITH
IN HOUSE RESOURCES SO THE
FUNDING FOR THOSE POSITIONS.
AGAIN DIRECTOR BILL AND- CAN
CONFIRM BUT THOSE HAVE BEEN IN
HOUSE RESOURCES WE'VE
REPURPOSED. AN EXISTING SYSTEM
THAT WAS BUILT FOR PRIOR
PROJECT FOR AGENCIES. OUR VERY
GOOD WITH. THAT'S OKAY ALL
RIGHT WELL WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
HOLD MATTER- OPEN AND I'M THANK
YOU FOR BUT THIS MORNING WE
WILL HEAR THE PUBLIC COMMENT
LATER- ALL THE FOLKS IN ZOOM
WORLD WE NEED TO ACTUALLY TAKE
A BREAK NOW BECAUSE WE HAVE A
FOR HIGH SAFETY PROTOCOLS WE
HAVE TO CHANGE OUT OF OUR-
CONSULTANT WHO WORKS ON THIS SO
I WILL WE WILL BE ON A
TEMPORARY BREAK BEFORE WE START
PART B. WHICH IS HAS ONE
DISCUSSION ITEM ON THE SENATE
CAP AND TRADE SPENDING PROPOSAL.
ONE LET'S CALL QUORUM BEFORE WE
TAKE THAT BREAK- MR HACKER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BY KELSEY
HERE DOLLY MCGUIRE STERN. FOR
OKAY SIR IS NOT HERE YET THAT
WE HAVE A QUORUM TO STAB WISH
LET'S TAKE A BREAK CAN SWITCH
UP CONSULTANCY.
OKAY BACK ON
THE RECORD OF. THE SENATE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE TO WILL RESUME. WE
HAVE ON PART B. WE HAVE. NINE
ISSUES EIGHT OF THEM. OUR NOW
WE HAVE THIRTEEN ISSUES
THIRTEEN ISSUES ONLY ONE ON
DISCUSSION- I GUESS YOU'RE
WELCOME FOR THE NATURAL
RESOURCES OF MOVED TO THEIR NEW
BUILDING THE CONSERVATION CORPS
IN THE AND THE FIRE SERVICE
HAVING THEIR EMERGENCY RESPONSE
AND SICK A SINGLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT SICK MIND EXCITED
GETTING SOME FUNDING AS WELL AS
A RECYCLING. PROGRAM SO LET'S
MOVE TO THE LA YO PRESENTATION
ON THE SENATE SOME- CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAMS AND HIGH I WOULD
LIKE FOR ALL THE SECRETARIES ON
THE LINE AND PEOPLE THIS IS I'D
LIKE TO HAVE A THEME YOU KNOW
FROM THE TURTLE SONG BACK IN
THE SIXTIES YOU KNOW HAPPY
TOGETHER RATHER THAN THE FRANK%
SINATRA I DO IT MY WAY ALL
RIGHT AND I KNOW I KNOW FRANKIE
IS A FAVORITE WITH EVERYBODY.
AND WE LIKE IT MY WAY BUT I'M
THINKING HAPPY TOGETHER SO
MISTER BROWN YOU'RE ON. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AGAIN ROSS BROWN WITH THE L. A.
O. COMMITTEE STAFF HAS ASKED US
TO PRESENT THE SENATE DEMOCRATS
TALKING TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN.
I WOULD JUST OUTLINED IN THEIR
AGENDA- AND SO I'M NOT GOING TO
GO OVER EVERY SINGLE DETAIL BUT
BY JUST SOME HIGH LEVEL
COMMENTS AND BACKGROUND. THE
FIRST SOME BACKGROUND- AS YOU
PROBABLY REMEMBER IN LIGHT OF
THE REVENUE UNCERTAINTY LAST
YEAR OF THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDED ONLY LIMITED GIGI R.
F. FUNDS MOSTLY FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIVITIES AS
WELL AS SOME WILDFIRE
ACTIVITIES AS PART OF LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET- AND THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL THIS YEAR INCLUDED. A
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING PLAN
THAT SPANNED OVER BOTH THE
CURRENT YEAR AS WELL AS THE
BUDGET YEAR SO I WAS KIND OF A
TWO YEAR PLAN- SINCE THAT TIME
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ADOPTED ONE
PIECE OF THE CURRENT YEAR PLAN
IF THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED WHICH
WAS THE- ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
WILDFIRE- THIS PART OF THE
WILDFIRE PACKAGE EARLIER THIS
YEAR- BUT IT'S STILL NOT
ADOPTED A COUPLE SCHOOLS- SCALE
KIND OF CURRENT YEAR PACKAGING
SO THAT KIND OF BRINGS US TO
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW. AND AS
YOU CAN SENIOR GENDER THE
SENATE PLAN- WOULD ALLOCATE ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TO
G. R. US- THAT TOTAL AMOUNT IS
BASED LARGELY ON- SOME OF OUR
REVENUE ESTIMATES THAT WE
SHARED WITH- WITH THE COMMITTEE
ARE INVITED TO THE SENATE.
WHICH ARE ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS HIGHER THAN THE
GOVERNOR CHANDERI BUDGET OVER
THERE TWO YEARS OVER BUT THE
CURRENT YEAR AND THE BUDGET
YEAR. THAT'S BASED ON RESULTS
FROM SOME OF THE MOST RECENT
AUCTION IN FEBRUARY AS WELL AS
SOME OF THE RECENT MARKET
TRENDS- AND IS ASSUMES
ESSENTIALLY I'LL BE ALLOWED TO
SELL AT THE MINIMUM PRICE WHICH
IS KIND OF CONSISTENT WITH-
COMMENTS ORACLE TRENDS. NOW AS
YOU KNOW A LARGE CHUNK OF THAT
ADDITIONAL REVENUE UNDER
CURRENT LAW GOES TO GENERAL'S
APPROPRIATIONS AND SO THAT
LEAVES A SMALLER CHUNK FOR
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING BUT
THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
AVAILABLE BASED ON OUR
ESTIMATES. I SO BASED ON THAT
WE DO THINK THAT- ABOUT OE
FOUR BILLION. TO BE ALEX- BASED
ON ADDRESS ASKING WHILE ALL
MAKING. A VERY REASONABLE AND
HEALTHY RESEARCH WHICH I THINK
IS IMPORTANT GIVEN THE REVENUE
UNCERTAINTY. AS YOU CAN SEE THE
SENATE PLAN INCLUDES ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION WHICH IS A LITTLE
BIT HIGHER THAN THAT NUMBER WE
PROVIDED- AND THAT'S BECAUSE IT
PROPOSES TO USE SOME OTHER
FUNDS OR- STEVEN AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER. WHICH FREES UP
ANOTHER HUNDRED MILLION SO LIKE
THAT'S WHAT GETS YOU TO THE ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION TOTAL NUMBER.
SO THE- REAL QUICKLY I WANT TO
JUST SOME OF THE HIGH LEVEL
MAJOR CHANGES IN THE PACKAGE
RELATIVE TO THE PROPOSAL THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION PUT FORWARD
EARLIER IN THE YEAR- ONE IS
THAT THERE ARE SOME SHIFTS AND
EXPENDITURES- TO OTHER FUNDS
WHETHER THEY BE GENERAL FINDS
FEDERAL FUNDS OR OTHER SPECIAL
FUNDS. FOR EXAMPLE EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN FUNDING THE SHIFTED.
AWAY FROM GRS TOWARDS- TOWARDS
GENERAL FUND AS WELL AS THAT
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL FUNDS.
THE FARMER PROGRAM AS YOU
DISCUSSED AS PART OF YOUR AG
PACKAGE WOULD BE SHIFTED TO
GENERAL FUND. ON IT SO IT THIS
FREEZE UP SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR US SPENDING IN
OTHER AREAS THAT WEREN'T
INCLUDED- OR AT LEAST-
INCREASING FUNDING- IN AREAS OF
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED AND SO.
THE MOST KEY AREAS OUR LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION- THE
SENATE PLAN INCLUDES. ONE
BILLION DOLLARS TOTAL FOR LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION THAT'S
OVER TWO YEARS- NOTABLY IT
INCLUDES- FUNDING FOR US YOU B.
R. P. YOU CAN BE A CALL REBATE
PROJECT WHICH WAS NOT PART OF
THAT. THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL-
TWO ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING FOR LOCAL ORGANIC WASTE
RECYCLING PROGRAMS. TO SUPPORT
THE GOALS ESTABLISHED BY S. S.
B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. WHICH
WAS NOT I CAN NOT PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S ORIGINAL PROPOSAL.
OTHER BRAVE OTHER ALLOCATIONS
TO OTHER PROGRAMS INCLUDING
COASTAL RESILIENCY LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENTS- NOTHING
REDUCTIONS WETLAND RESTORATION
AND FINER RESEARCH SO I'M NOT
GONNA GO THROUGH ALL OF THOSE
BUT THEY'RE NICELY LAID. OUT ON
THE TABLE IN YOUR AGENDA. I
JUST WANT I WANT TO BEFORE. AND
IN MY CAR HERE- I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE. A THAT THIS IS A
CENTRAL. A ONE POINT BILLION
DISCUSS PACKED. ACTUALLY TWO
YEARS OF DISCUSS FUND SOME-
FULL SCALE DISCRETIONARY
FUNDING PLAN WAS NOT ADOPTED AS
PART OF THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET
AND SO. THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING AVAILABLE
NEXT YEAR AS YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT YOUR LONG TERM PLANS. IS
LIKELY TO BE BACK. UP TO AROUND
EIGHT HUNDRED TO NINE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS DOLLARS.
ANNUALLY AND SO I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN MIND WHEN
THINKING ABOUT. LONG TERM
PLANNING FOR HOW MUCH
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS. SO I WILL IN MY
COMMENTS THERE ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THIS
BROWN COULD YOU. ON THE IMPACT
THIS SPENDING PROGRAM WILL HAVE
ON CARBON REDUCTION I KNOW A
LOT OF TIMES WE GET INTO AIR
POLLUTION. DISCUSSION OTHER
INTERNAL LOTS OF DEMANDS FROM
PROGRAMS IF PEOPLE WANT BUT
BUT- PUTTING IN FOR INSTANCE ON
THE ON THE CAL RECYCLE ON THE
ORGANIC WASTE A TWO HUNDRED
MILLION WHAT. WHAT COULD WE
ANTICIPATE FOR THE ACTUAL
CARBON IMPACT THAT THAT TYPE
OF- EXPENDITURE PLANNER. BUT
POTENTIAL EXPENDITURE PLAN.
YEAH I DON'T I MEAN I DON'T
THINK- WE HAVE ANY KIND OF-
SPECIFIC OUTCOME QUANTITATIVE
SORT OF OUTCOME MEASURES BASED
ON THE PLAN THAT HAS BEEN
PROVIDED TO US BUT- CLEARLY-
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
AND METHANE IS A- SIGNIFICANT
SOURCE OF THE STATE'S OVERALL
EMISSIONS AND- LOOKING AT THE-
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SCOPING PLAN
THAT THEIR RESOURCES BOARD PUT
TOGETHER. METHANE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS BOTH ON THE VERY
SIDE AS WELL AS THE WASTE SIDE-
ARE A LARGE CHUNK ABOUT A THIRD
OF KIND OF THE EXPECTED
EMISSION REDUCTIONS KIND OF
NEEDED TO MEET THE STATE'S
TWENTY THIRTY GOALS SO THAT'S A
BIG. BIG CHUNK OF THE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS ARE EXPECTED AND SO-
YEAH I THINK THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THAT PART OF THE PLAN SORT OF
TARGET STATEN OTHER QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW MUCH STATE BUDGET
SUPPORT IS NEEDED VERSUS JUST
SORT OF REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS
BUT- I'M CLEARLY IT'S SORT OF
TARGETS ONE OF THE MAIN SOURCES
OF- OF EMISSIONS IN THE STATE
AND- ONE OF THE GOALS OF THE
STATE HAS FOR ACHIEVING ITS-
ITS CHARTERS. AS BEEN AND- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A COUPLE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
PREVIOUSLY ONE FOR. A COMES UP
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE FOR A
MILLION CLEAN CARS ON THE ROAD
IS HAVE CARS AND THEN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION A COUPLE OF GOVERNORS.
HAVE HAVE- THOSE ARE AS GOALS.
THIS TYPE OF FUNDING PLAN. WITH
THE CALM. OF THE MEDIUM SIZE
TRUCKS THE LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES.
I PRESUME IT GETS US CLOSER TO
THAT GOAL DO YOU WANT TO. GIVE
US YOUR CRYSTAL BALL OF THE IS
THIS THE TYPE OF INVESTMENT
THAT WE NEED IN ORDER TO HELP
WITH THE MARKET PLACE AND
CONSUMERS. ARE HELP US ACHIEVE
THOSE GOALS. YEAH I MEAN I
THINK THERE'S A THERE'S WE HAD
KIND OF A- FAIRLY LENGTHY
DISCUSSION IN A- JOINT HEARING
A FEW WEEKS AGO- YEAH THESE ARE
THE GOALS THAT HAVE BEEN SENT
OUT ARE ARE. QUITE AMBITIOUS
AND SO- WILL NEED TO BE KIND OF
A LOT OF STATE POLICIES.
IMPLEMENTED IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
THOSE AMBITIOUS GOALS- I THINK
MORE FUNDING KIND OF IN A LOT
OF THOSE AREAS CAN BE ONE PIECE
OF THAT. PUZZLE I THINK. THE
CHALLENGE COMES IN AND KIND OF
YOU KNOW HOW HOW THOSE POLICIES
IN THAT BUDGETS ARE GONNA RACKS
WITH. REGULATORY PROGRAMS AND
ALL THOSE DIFFERENT PIECES FIT
TOGETHER SO THAT MAKES THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT MAKES
IT. DIFFICULT TO KIND OF. PUT A
QUANTITATIVE NUMBER ON KIND OF
EXACTLY THE SORT OF. HOW FAR
THIS FUNDING MOTORISTS AND WHAT
OTHER KIND OF POLICIES AND
ACTIONS ARE NEEDED BUT- I THINK
IT'S FAIR TO SAY SORT OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SUPPORT IN A
LOT OF THESE AREAS- CAN KIND OF
HELP US GET. AT LEAST PART OF
HE WAY THERE. OKAY TODAY I
GUESS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THAT WE'RE CONCERNED WITH NOT
GOING TO GET ON TO SECTORS
BECAUSE THEY TOO BUT- YOU KNOW
THE- THE- GOING BACK TO THE-
THE SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS I KNOW WE HAVE SOME
MONEY. WHICH WE'VE GOT SOME NON
ATTAINMENT AREAS THAT THAT THE
FIRE SERVICE ON THE PRESCRIBED
BURN PROGRAM IS ALWAYS YOU
KNOW. A BALANCING ARE WEGET A
BI IS. HERE QUALITY COULD BE AT
SUCH A- POSITION THAT WE'RE TO
BE ABLE GO FOR. WITH A PRESS.
BURN VERSES. BECAUSE OF THESE
YOU KNOW POLLUTING. LANDFILLS
ARE POLLUTING CARS AND ALL
THESE THINGS THAT THAT THEY DID
NOT A TEAM AND- KOCIAN IS SO
HIGH THAT THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
DO IT- I GUESS THE QUESTION IS
THAT IS DOES ONE YEAR
INVESTMENT. HELP US REACH THAT
YOU KNOW BRING THOSE. ARE HERE
CALL THE NUMBERS DOWN SAID THAT
THESE CARBON REDUCTION MEASURES
CAN GO FORWARD DO YOU HAVE ANY
OPINION ON THAT IS THAT I MEAN
IS THAT A GOOD BLUEPRINT THAT
WERE. WHAT ARE THINKING HERE IN
THE SENATE. I'M I'M- I THINK
KIND OF ANYTHING TO- KIND OF
HELP CONTRIBUTE TO SORT OF THE
STATE CAN SORT OF REGIONAL
EFFORTS TO BRING SOME OF THOSE
LOCAL AIR POLLUTANTS DOWN IS-
IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION PARTICULARLY IN
CERTAIN AREAS AND STYLES- YOU
KNOW IT'S ALWAYS I THINK IT IS
IT'S KIND OF DEVELOPING A
COUNTRY THAT'S BEEN A FOR
PLANETS ALWAYS SORT OF A- A
BALANCE OF KIND OF YOU KNOW
CARBON REDUCTIONS IN FOCUSING
EXCLUSIVELY ON CARBON
REDUCTIONS AND KIND OF THOUGHT
ABOUT SOME OF THESE OTHER GOALS
THAT THE- THE STATE'S TRYING TO
ACHIEVE I DON'T KNOW THAT WE'VE
SORT OF SPEND. ENOUGH TIME
LOOKING AT KIND OF THE SENATE
PLAN AND KIND OF HOW IT SORT OF
BALANCES THOSE TWO THINGS ARE
KIND OF YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
THINKING AROUND SO YOU KNOW THE
SPECIFIC QUESTION THAT YOU
ASKED BUT I'M HAPPY TO KIND OF
DISCUSS IT MORE AS
CONVERSATIONS GO FORWARD- AND
CHAT WITH YOU AND STAFF ABOUT
KIND OF SEE HOW TO PROCEED WITH
THE SENATE SCHOOLS ARE
EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT LET'S OF
LET'S GO THE ADMINISTRATION
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD SECRETARY
ROSS SECTOR CROWFOOT SECTOR
BLUMENFELD. WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
LEAD OFF. ABSOLUTELY J. THAT-
CHAD- MEMBERS THANK YOU TO THE-
SPEAK. MY NAME IS GERMAN CHILD
I'M THE CALIFORNIA SECRETARY
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION-
THE STOCK- SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
YOU THAT HAPPY TOGETHER. THANK
YOU FOR THE SUPPORT OF THE LOW
CARBON. TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
AS THE L. A. O. JUST DESCRIBED
AS- THE SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANT PROGRAM SOMEWHAT
CLOSE TRAINING. AND FROM
MITIGATION AND RESILIENCE
PROGRAMS AND- HOPEFULLY-
WORKING HAPPY TOGETHER SHORTLY
I WILL I WANT TO GO THROUGH
SOME OF THE SIX SEVENTEEN- I'M
RATIONALE AND- AND TALK A
LITTLE BIT OF DETAIL ABOUT SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS YOU ADDRESS.
DIVING INTO AS IT RELATES TO
ADD POLLUTION- AS YOU KNOW JUST
TO RECAP THE CAP AND TRADE HAS
GENERATED ALMOST THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE AUCTION
PROCEEDS TO FUND THESE CRITICAL
CLIMATE. INVESTMENT PROGRAMS
OVER THE YEARS AND CHANGES TO
YOUR LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP AND
THE DIRECTION TO PRIORITIZE
INVESTMENTS AND DISADVANTAGED
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AS
ENVISAGED IN SB. FIVE THIRTY
FIVE IN AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
DIRECTING PROJECTS TOWARDS
THESE COMMUNITIES IS A KEY
OBJECTIVE OF THE FILES. WE
CONTINUE TO SET AN EXAMPLE FOR
OTHER NATIONAL AND SUBNATIONAL
CLIMATE PROGRAMS BY EMPHASIZING
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND EQUITY
IN PROGRAM DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENTATION. AND THIS YEAR
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROJECT
BUDGET PROPOSED TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION SAID
COMMUNITY AFTER SEXUAL PROGRAMS
CREATED TO EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN. THESE REDUCE
EMISSIONS IN COMMUNITIES WITH
DISPROPORTIONATE EXPOSURE TO
AIR POLLUTION YOUR TARGETED
MONITORING COMMUNITY EMISSION
REDUCTION PROGRAMS AND
INCENTIVES GRANTS TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND
IMPLEMENTATION. FUNDING FOR
LOCAL AT DISTRICTS. AS WE WORK
TOWARDS ACHIEVING CLIMATE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE MAINTAIN AN
INTERSECTIONAL APPROACH TO OUR
PROGRAMS AND INVESTMENTS. WE
HAVE TO PRIORITIZE THOSE
PROGRAMS THAT DELIVER MULTIPLE
BENEFITS THAT CAN REDUCE
CLIMATE IMPACTS IMPROVE THEIR
QUALITY AND HEALTH AND OPTIMIZE
OPPORTUNITIES. TO ACHIEVE
EQUITABLE OUTCOMES IN DECISION
MAKING. THIS APPROACH IS KEY
NOT ONLY TO OUR PORTFOLIO OF
INVESTMENTS GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND DOLLARS IT ALSO
UNDERLIES OUR BROUGHT A FUNDING
STRATEGY INCLUDING THE MAY.
REVISED TO BE ANALYSIS THURSDAY.
WHEN WE CAN BEFORE YOU A MARCH
WE DISCUSS THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED G. ACTION RESTAURANT.
ADVISE ACT AND JUSTICE
PROTECTING HEALTH AND DRIVING
COMPREHENSIVE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. THE EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN PROGRAM IS CRITICAL
TO SUPPORTING OUR EFFORTS TO
ADVANCE EQUITY AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. THE PROGRAM ENABLES
RESIDENTS TO PLAY AN ACTIVE
ROLE IN THE DESIGN OF EMISSIONS
REDUCTION STRATEGIES FOR THAT
COMMUNITIES. AS WELL AS THE
STATE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN AND
SCOPING PLAN PROCESS SEES. THE
COR PAPPAS AT EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN REMAINS AMBITIOUS TO
ELIMINATE DISPARITIES AND AIR
QUALITY WHILE ACHIEVING FEDERAL
ACT COOL BUT THE STANDARDS
CURRENTLY SIX OF THE NATION'S
TEN CITIES OF THE WEST EQUITY
ARE IN CALIFORNIA. PROVING ARE
AREAS WITH A FIFTY IS STRUGGLE
AND IT'S ONLY WITH THE RECENT
PASSAGE OF SIX SEVENTEEN AND A
COMMUNITIES NOW HAVE A REAL
SEAT AT THE TABLE. TO ADD
QUALITY PLANNING. THE ROAD
AHEAD WILL NEED TO QUICK NO.
THE COMMUNITIES WE PRIORITIZE
EXPERIENCE POOR AIR QUALITY
POLLUTION BUTTONS AND OFTEN
BROWN RIPPLE TO CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS. BECAUSE OF THE
PERSISTENT DYNAMICS AT THE
LOCAL AND REGIONAL LEVEL FOR
WHICH THEY NEED OUR SUPPORT.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE PARTNERS CONTINUE TO
EXPRESS HOW CRITICAL IT IS TAT
COPY INVOLVED IN ALL ASPECTS OF
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION AND THAT
WE PRIORITIZE ACTIONS TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS THAT GO BEYOND
INCENTIVES. COBBS ROLE IN
DELIVERING SUPPORT TO
COMMUNITIES ENGAGE IN THE SIX
SEVENTEEN ACTIVITIES IS KEY TO
ACHIEVING THE PROGRAM'S GOALS.
AND THE PROPOSED TWENTY TWO
STOCKS ARE INTEGRAL TO BUILDING
TRUST AT THE COMMUNITY LEVEL
ELEVATING COMMUNITY PRIORITIES
TO THE AD DISTRICTS. AND THE
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THOMAS DASCHLE WE ASK THAT YOU
RECONSIDER THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE THE
CONTINUING RESOURCES REQUIRED
TO REALIZE THE FULL PROMISE OF
THIS CRITICAL AB SIX SEVENTEEN
PROGRAM. WHICH LIES AT THE
CROSSROADS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
RETAINING THIS PROGRAM AS PART
OF A I ESQUE PHOTO OF
INVESTMENT SENDS TWO IMPORTANT
MESSAGES. REINVESTING IN THE
LONG TERM SUCCESS OF SIX
SEVENTEEN AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT SOME VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
AROUND THE GLOBE. AB POLLUTION
AND CLIMATE CHANGE. A TWO SIDES
OF THE SAME COIN. ON OUTSIDE OF
IT TODAY EXECUTIVE OFFICER EACH
CHIANG MATH THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE JOHNSON THE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT
A LACK IN IMPLEMENTING SIX
SEVENTEEN ABOUT OUT PROPOSED
EXPENSES BECAUSE- THANK YOU FOR
THE CONSIDERATION OF THESE
POINTS I'M ALSO AVAILABLE.
TIMES ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE FOR ME I GUESS I GUESS THE
FIRST QUESTION IS THAT YOU KNOW
THIS ISN'T AIR POLLUTION
PROGRAM THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS A 100% BEING PAID FROM A
CARBON REDUCTION AND- I GUESS
THE- THE- THE IDEA HERE IS. TO
BALLENSTEDT YOU KNOW THEY'VE
GOT MONEY IN THE AIR POLLUTION
FINE YOU GOT MONEY- IN THE IN.
THE LOCAL THE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS I AM NOT. THIS YEAR'S
THE- SAYS FOR ONE YEAR PAID OUT
OF THESE OTHER FUNDS. OBVIOUSLY
NEXT YEAR WE HAVE TO COME BACK
BUT IF THE GOAL IS AIR
POLLUTION. AND WE'RE ALL WE'RE
ALL SECRETARIES AND TECHNICAL
PEOPLE ADMINISTRATION FOLKS WE
KNOW THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
CARBON REDUCTION. AND POLLUTION
IN PUBLIC HEALTH WHY IS THE
PUBLIC HEALTH ADMINISTRATION
NOT SHIPPING IN SOME MONEY TO
HELP OUT WITH THIS OUTREACH
PROGRAM PROGRAM'S FIFTEEN GAUGE.
PEOPLE I MEAN IT'S A IT'S A
QUESTION OF THE BALANCE OF WHAT
PORTION OF IT IS CARBON
REDUCTION I'M NOT SAYING
THERE'S NO CARBON REDUCTION BUT
A LOT OF IT IS. IS YOU KNOW
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
BUDGET IS TO FOR HIRE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICT. PERSONNEL IN BLIGHTED
IT WHEN. WHEN YOU COME THAT
CLOSE TO THE CHARGE OF. THE THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM. WELL AT
TUESDAY'S VISIBLE AND THE OTHER
RELATED TO AIR POLLUTION- AND
YOU CAN DENY THIS BUT I THINK
JUST FOR THE PUBLIC AS WELL AS
REITERATING- THE MAJOR CLEAN
AIR ACT LANDMARK DECISION OF
THE SUPREME COURT WAS TO DECIDE
THAT CABIN WAS INTACT AND
POLLUTION THAT REQUIRED- ASKED
TO REGULATED UNDER THE CLEAN
AIR ACT- SO I DEFINITELY SEE
CABIN AS ABSOLUTION- AND AS A
AS A POLLUTANT I'M IN TERMS OF
THE LOCAL AD DISTRICTS ROLE-
AND IS. REGULATE STATIONERY'S
OF POLLUTION. MANY OF WHICH
CONTRIBUTE BOTH- CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS AND CARBON POLLUTION
AND IN THAT LOCAL AREA- WHAT WE
FOUND. IS THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
INSPECTION WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE A LOT OF COMMUNITIES
ARE SUFFERING TODAY FROM
ABSOLUTION- IN THE FORM OF
ASTHMA IN THE FORM OF INCREASED
MORTALITY. FROM PM TWO POINT
FIVE- AND A LOT OF THE SAME
SOURCES ALSO AS SOURCES OF
CARBON POLLUTION SO OFTEN. AS
YOU KNOW IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
DIFFICULT TO DETACH- AND
UNNECESSARY IN MANY CASES TO
SAY THIS DIESEL TRUCK- IS.
ALLUDING JUST DIESEL THE TICKET
WHAT MATTER ALSO. A LEADING
COMPING COLLISION INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE SO WE THINK THIS IS
ACTUALLY A VERY INNOVATIVE WAY
OUT AN IMPORTANT WAY TO USE
TEACHER AT FUNDING. THE ROLE
THAT THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
BOARD PLACES CRITICAL. IN THAT
IT IS A VERY DECENTRALIZED
CHAD- DECENTRALIZED. WAY IN
WHICH GOVERNMENTS HAPPENS IN
CALIFORNIA- NO NO WHERE ELSE IN
THE COUNTRY HAS THIRTY FOUR AT
DISTRICTS- AND AN AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND A COUNTY PA WE HAVE A
LOT A LOT OF GOVERNANCE AND A
LOT OF GROUND THAT NEEDS TO BE
COVERED. AND SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET THE
DECISION MAKING RIGHT. IF WE
COME OUT WITH CLIMATE SOLUTIONS
THAT ARE NOT ACCEPTABLE OR NOT
INVOLVING LOCALS. FROM THE
EARLIEST STAGES IN THE DESIGN
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE
RULES- WE RUN THE RISK OF US
NOT INVOLVING THE VERY PEOPLE
WHO ARE. THE MOST VULNERABLE TO
CRIME AND OTHER IMPACTS SO YEAH
I THINK IS A VERY VALID- USE OF
G. FUNDING- ASPECT GIVEN. THE
GENESIS OF THE MOST RECENT
ITERATION OF HOW SHE- FUNDING
CAME IN BEING- AND AS IT
RELATES TO THE COP STAFF I
THINK. THEY THEY PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN HELPING US TO
SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. YEAH I JUST I JUST
WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT OTHER
AGENCIES WHO CONTRIBUTE TO WHO
ARE INTERESTED IN THIS IN THIS-
A DESIRED OUTCOMES SHE NEEDING
KICK IN A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY
FROM THEIR BUDGETS IN ORDER TO
GET ENTERING. I MEAN WHETHER
YOU HAVE KICKED THE COMMUNITY
ENGAGED OR NOT IF YOU PUT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS INTO
MAKING YOUR GREEN WASTE WORK
RIGHTS YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE
EMISSIONS WHETHERPEOPLE
UNDERSTAND IT OR YOU CAN
EXPLAIN IT OR HAVE. A PARTY
ABOUT IT IF THAT IF THOSE
INVESTMENTS GOING TO LOW INCOME
AREAS AND THEY ACTUALLY SEE THE
MEASURABLE REDUCTIONS OF
METHANE OR THE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR AUTOMOBILES AND- TRUCKS
THOSE ARE GOING TO AFFECT THE
PORTS SEEK YOU CAN'T SPEND THAT
MUCH MONEY ON HIGH HEAVY TO.
MEDIUM SIZE VEHICLES OR TRUCKS
AND NOT PRODUCE IT SO IT'S THE
OUTCOMES I THINK WE'RE ON THE
WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE WITH ITS
THE PATHWAY THAT WE GO. AND
WHETHER THIS PROGRAM PAYS THE
ENTIRE NOT OF THE OF EVERYTHING
THAT'S IMAGINABLE THE PEOPLE
COME UP WITH. VERSUS YOU KNOW
COMMUNITY OUT REACH. THE PUBLIC
HEALTH THESE OTHER THESE OTHER
PROGRAMS- LESS. OKAYED CENTER
DOLLY YEAH WE DID I DIDN'T HEAR
THE SECRETARYSHIP SOME SORRY
WELL I WANTED TO JUST FOLLOW UP
ON YOUR- TAT. YOU'RE
QUESTIONING EXPECTS ON AND IF I
COULD. UNDER THIS SECTION IT IS
KEPT AS IT'S CALLED IN LEAST ON
WHAT I HAVE AVAILABLE TO ME.
EQUITY PROGRAM SO FAR I'M
TRYING TO GET MY HEAD AROUND.
ACTUALLY HOW IT'S GONNA WORK
WHAT TELL CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO ME
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
COMMUNITY GROUPS IS AND HOW
THAT'S GOING TO REDUCE CARBON
IN THAT AREA I MEAN WE HAVE. WE
KNOW- THAT YOU KNOW IN THE
VALLEY THAT THERE'S AS AS
MENTIONED BY THE SECRETARY
THAT- WE HAVE THE WORST AIR INS
ARE SEVEN OF THE TEN I THINK
WERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT HOW DOES
THIS ACTUALLY GONNA. WORK ON
THE GROUND THE DEVIL'S IN THE
DETAILS AND I'M A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSED ON. HOW IT'S GONNA
WORK AND HOW IT'S GOING TO
ACTUALLY REDUCE CARBON IN THOSE
AREAS AND POLLUTION. LIKE GET A
SATURDAY HOME MEET I'M HAPPY TO
GIVE A SCENARIO SAYS. UNDER THE
CLEAN AIR ACT- THE NATIONAL
AMBIENT AIR QUALITY STANDARDS
AS SET BY THE UNITED STATES
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
AND- UNFORTUNATELY SHE- KLEIN
SAYS IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
AND THE SOUTH COAST DISTRICT
WHICH INCLUDES MOST OF
METROPOLITAN ADELAIDE. THE LAST
FIFTY YEARS WE HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO ACHIEVE AT QUALITY
STANDARDS- THE STATE IS
OBLIGATED TO COME OUT WITH. A
REGIONAL ASH SAID- PLANS CALL
TO STATE IMPLEMENTATION PLANS.
THOSE PLANS LOOK AT THE ENTIRE
REGION SO TO YOUR CLIENT. LET'S
FOCUS ON THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
THERE'S A PLAN THE STATE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN. THAT THAT-
BOARD. APPROVES A GIVE AND GOES
TO. THE STATE AND THEN GOES TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
STATE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN ONLY
LOOKS AT. REGIONAL ACTIVITIES
AND WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT.
HEALTH BENEFITS TO LOCAL
DISADVANTAGED ENVIRONMENTALLY
JUSTICE IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
ARE NOT TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION SIGNIFICANTLY IN
THAT REGIONAL. ASSET PLANNING
PROCESS AND SO SIX SEVENTEEN-
WHEN IT WAS PASSED- WHAT. LED
TO THAT AND DISTRICTS. WITH
THEIR RESOURCES BOARD TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH AND FIND LOCAL
COMMUNITY PLANNING GROUNDS TO
SAY HOW CAN WE- REDUCE. AND
ACHIEVE THESE ATTACK HOLDING
CLIMATE GOALS WHILE ACTUALLY
HELPING THE NEEDS OF LOCAL
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THERE IS A
SENSE THAT IT WAS JUST REGION
OVERLY REGION LIES- AND- BACK.
I MET YOU KNOW IS THIS GLOBAL
ISSUE HOW WE- HOW LOCAL P. SET
AS IT'S INCLUDING IN THE GO OF
APTLY IN COBB REDUCTION. THE
NEEDS OF LOW COMMUNITIES AND
THE CAPACITY TO ACT HAVE A SEAT
AT THE TABLE TO PLAN- THOSE
CHANGES SO I'LL I'LL GIVE AN
EXAMPLE THE. CHEN SAYS WE ALL
AGREE THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE-
SPENDING FOOD WASTE WHICH EMITS
METHANE TO THE LEFT AND STILL-
IT ALSO- CAUSES ALL KINDS OF
OTHER ISSUES BUT- MAKING SURE
THAT. FOR INSTANCE THE TRUCKS
OF THE DRIVING THROUGH THE
COMMUNITY ON THE WAY TO THE
LEFT AND STILL ARE ALSO CLEANED
OUT THAT THE COMMUNITIES
INVOLVED IN MAKING SURE THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
PARKWAY OF THAT TRUCK LOOKS
LIKE HAS NOT BEEN CONSIDERED-
THOSE WOULD JUST DRIVING RIGHT
THROUGH ALL PARKING THOSE-
FLEET OF RESCUE RESCUES
VEHICLES IN LOW INCOME THIS IS
NOT AS COMMUNITIES AS KIND OF
CONCERNS NEED TO BE INTEGRATED
AND OTHERWISE WE HAVE HUGE
BACKLASH TO THESE PROGRAMS WE
THINK THAT WE'RE RESULT
RESULTING IN THESE REDUCTIONS
BUT IN FACT. WE THAT HAVE
COMMUNITY STANDING UP AND SAY
ACTUALLY WE DON'T LIKE THE WAY
THAT THE SUIT SCRAPS OF BEING
BROUGHT TO THIS BY LARGE
DISTANCES OF THE WE NEED TO
CHANGE THEM AND WHEN YOU DO
THAT AFTER THE FACT OF
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE DESTRUCTIVE
AND MORE EXPENSIVE SO BY
INTEGRATING THE VOICES OF
COMMUNITIES EARLY ON WE BUT
IT'S GET REDUCTIONS THAT HELP
WITH HEALTH. HELD REDUCE
IMPACTS- AND MAKE THE PROGRAM
MORE SUCCESSFUL SO HAVE YOU
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION- THE
DISPLACEMENT THAT MEANS I KNOW
THAT. WHEN I WAS ON THE SIERRA
CONSERVING. THERE IS MANY
STUDIES THAT IF YOU TOOK. EVERY
PERSON AND EVERY ANYBODY
EVERYTHING OUT OF FRESNO COUNTY
YOU WOULD STILL HAVE. THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE IT'S QUITE
FRANKLY SOME OF IT IS. COMING
FROM OTHER AREAS AND IT SETTLES
IN THAT BASIN AND SO FOR. JUST
KIND OF IT MAY BE A I GUESS A
COMMENT FOR ME- MMHM THE GOAL
IS TO MAKE THEIR CLEAN AT THE
END OF THE DAY AND IN EVERY
LOCALITY BUT SOME LOCALITIES
HAVE SOME VERY CHALLENGING.
DEMOGRAPHICS JUST BECAUSE OF
THE SIERRAS AND THE WAY THE AIR
LIGHT LIES IN THE BASIN AND YOU
AND- SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS-
FOR ME IT'S OF IT'S ABOUT HOW
WE SPEND THE RESOURCE WE HAVE
YOU KNOW I'VE OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S- NO SECRET THAT I'M NOT
A BIG FAN OF THE- THE BULLET
TRAIN OR THE VALLEY TRAIN
SYSTEM ON I THINK WE SHOULD BE.
SPENDING THOSE RESOURCES IN
AREAS WHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY
REDUCE. THE CARBON OUTPUT- AND
MOVE PEOPLE IN PLACES LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO THE AND LA. SO- SO
THERE'S A THERE'S A LOT OF
MONEY. GOING TO- THESE PROGRAMS
AND I'M NOT OPPOSED TO IT BUT I
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A
HOLISTIC APPROACH TO HOW WE
ACTUALLY SOLVE THE PROBLEM AND
I KNOW THAT THOSE FOLKS IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES. ARE VERY
FRUSTRATED I'VE HEARD THEM OVER
THE YEARS OPPOSE EVENING
LEGISLATION I WAS WORKING ON TO
DO STUFF WITH- WITH BIOMASS-
AND THEY POSE PLANTS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THEY PUT
OFF CARBON BUT IT WAS BETTER A
HECK OF A LOT BETTER THAN OPEN
BURNING. SO JUST SOME COMMENTS
I AM I WANT TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM WITH THIS IS THAT. THE
YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S REQUEST
HERE THE PART IS A LOT OF THIS
EVENING. IT'S A HUGE AMOUNT OF
DOLLARS THE SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVEN'T SEEN TO THIS MAGNITUDE
BEFORE. SO THANK YOU FOR SUCH
A- SIGNATURE BLEND FAILING TO
MOVE UNDER SECRETARY CROWFOOT
BUT- QUITE THE SENATE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR- AND YOUR RESOURCE FOR
PROGRAM FOR WOOD STOVE
REPLACEMENT. AND THIS WAS A
QUITE POPULAR- PROGRAM THAT
BEFORE YOU- BECAME SECRETARY-
AND IT HAS A DIRECT READ IT
DIRECTLY RESULTS IN. REDUCTION
OF EMISSIONS AND AIR QUALITY IT
ACTUALLY IMPROVES OUR QUALITY
AS WELL AS AS THE COMMISSION
WHAT TYPE OF. IMPACT DO YOU
THINK THE FIVE MILLION CAN HAVE
ON THE REMAINING. BAD STOVES I
GUESS THAT THERE. THE CHALLENGE
JIM THAT ARE UP THERE. MAYBE I
MEAN BACK LOVE THIS PROGRAM AS
WELL AND- WHEN I WAS A U. S. T.
PAY WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH
HIS STATE FOCUSING ON ON HOW
TO- SHE REALLY- INCIDENTS
PROGRAMS AND ACTUALLY JUST SEND
THE DALITS POINT THERE'S
THRIVING BUSINESSES TO MAKE THE
WOOD PALLETS FULL THIS DOES
THAT BAN CLEAN I AM AND IT'S A
GREAT WAY OF. CLEARING-
CLEARING AND SUPPLYING CLEAN
FUEL- SO YEAH THE THESE
PROGRAMS AGREED DEMONSTRABLE WE
CAN WE CAN SHOW YOU. YOU KNOW-
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS INVESTED.
HOW MUCH- CRITERIA AND CARBON
POLLUTION IS- REDUCE
SATISFACTORY ALL THESE PROGRAMS
THAT THE BENEFIT OF THEM IS
THAT THEY'RE VERY DEMONSTRABLE
IN TIMES OF. THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE FUNDING. AND THE
POLLUTION IS USED AS UNITS. ALL
KNOW- COMMITTEE. IT ALSO-
SOMETHING WE HAVEN'T TALKED
ABOUT FOR THE INDOOR AIR
POLLUTION. I'M RELATED TO SOME
OF THESE WOODS DOES IS ACTUALLY
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS FROM A
PUBLIC HEALTH PERSPECTIVE THAN
THAN ANY OF THAT. OUR GOAL
POLLUTION CREATED SAYS YEAH THE
GREAT PROGRAM. EXCELLENT LET'S
GO ON TO. A SECTOR CRAWFORD.
YOU'VE GOT THE SENATE HIS SHOWN
SOME. I'M PRO TO COME UNDER
YOUR THE- DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON A HEALTHY FORCE
WORKING LANDS- WETLAND
RESTORATION OR. YEAH I'LL BE
BRIEF- THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY YOU KNOW YOU
REFERENCE CHAIR HAPPY TOGETHER
AND THAT REFERS TO THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE BUT CERTAINLY
ACROSS AGENCIES SO I'M HERE
FIRST AND FOREMOST JUST TO
SUPPORT- JARRETT'S WORK AND
THAT THE WORK AT COUNTY PA IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE THIS IS
TRULY A WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT
EFFORT. TO TACKLE CLIMATE
CHANGE I'LL SAY THAT WERE
REALLY THANKFUL OF THE SENATE'S
VISION- THAT NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS BE PART OF OUR
SOLUTIONS TO COMBAT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THE INVESTMENTS IN
HEALTHY RESILIENT FORESTS AS
WELL AS OTHER LANDSCAPE SUCH AS
WETLANDS WE CONTINUE TO THINK
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
THE CLIMATE PUZZLE- AND ARE
REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF- THE
SENATE'S RECOGNITION OF THAT SO
I HERE OBVIOUSLY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND SIMPLY SUPPORT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S REQUEST.
YEAH IT DIED AS YOU KNOW ONE OF
THINGS ONE EMPHASIZES GIVEN THE
BUDGET THAT WE PROPOSED OR THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE HAVE ON
HEALTHY FOREST. OVER A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD THAT THE WITH THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO- STATUS TO ON
TOP SO THAT'S SOME MONEY COMES
FROM. CAP AND TRADE SOME MONEY
COMES FROM- THE- THE GENERAL
FUND THAT WE PUT AWAY-
SECRETARY ROSS YOU HAVE A- YOU
HAVE SOME METHANE REDUCTION AND
HEALTHY FOREST AND- PROGRAMS IN
HERE ALSO DO YOU HAVE A HAVE
YES I HAVE NOTHING REDUCTION IN
THE DAIRY SECTOR AS WELL AS
HEALTHY SOILS- AND I WANT TO
ECHO WHAT MY TWO COLLEAGUES
HAVE ALREADY THOUGHT ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK TOGETHER-
AND THESE VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS- AND CALL OUT IN
PARTICULAR THE ROLE OF FARMERS
AND RANCHERS- IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR- AND THE PARTNERSHIP
THAT THEY CREATED. ACROSS THE
LANDSCAPE WITH MANY OF OUR NGOS
TO REALLY ACHIEVE- THE STATE
ABILITY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP IN PARTICULAR IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HOLD UP THE
NATIONAL WORKING LANDS AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES WITH THAT WE HAVE
TO DRIVE DOWN CARBON IN SUPPORT
AND HOLD IT IN OUR SOILS ARE IN
OUR TREES- AND IN PARTICULAR
THE HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM- HAS
BEEN ESPECIALLY EFFECTIVE AT
THIS OFTENTIMES WHEN WE PARTNER
WITH FARMERS AND RANCHERS IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR. ON THESE
PROGRAMS WE SEE MULTIPLE
BENEFITS- AN EXAMPLE AND
HEALTHY SOILS IS NOT ONLY THE
ABILITY TO SEQUESTER CARBON AND
IMPROVE THE PRODUCTIVITY OF
THOSE SOILS- FOR LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY AND CROP
PRODUCTION BUT ALSO WATER
HOLDING CAPACITY. WHICH IN
CALIFORNIA IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT- IMPROVED NUTRIENT
CYCLING AND ENHANCING
BIODIVERSITY BECAUSE OF HOW
MUCH OF OUR BIODIVERSITY IS
ACTUALLY IN OUR SOILS- OVER THE
HISTORY OF THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM WE'VE GOTTEN
APPROXIMATELY FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS OUT TO OVER SIX HUNDRED
PROJECTS INCLUDING
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS TO SHOW
OTHER FARMERS THE PRACTICES
THAT WILL DO THESE- THESE. ARE
THE QUESTION IS. MAKE THE CUT
OF IMPROVE I TALK ABOUT THE ACT-
NEXT TONS OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS EQUIVALENTS THAT ARE
REDUCES OVER A HUNDRED AND
TWELVE. THOUSAND METRIC TONS
PER YEAR OVER THE LIFETIME OF
THESE PROJECTS. WITH REGARD TO
NOTHING REDUCTION ARE DAIRY
FAMILIES HAVE REALLY STEPPED UP
AND SHOWN LEADERSHIP IN THIS
REGARD WE HAVE TWO ELEMENTS ARE
NOTHING REDUCTION PROGRAM ONE
IS FOR TERRY DI TESTERS. FOR
THE GENERATION OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY- AND DOING THE JERRY
pALSO MAKING IMPROVEMENTS TO
REDUCE OUR OTHER. HI JERRY OF
POLLUTANTS. IN THE AIR AS WELL
AS- IMPROVED. ABILITY TO
MITIGATE WATER QUALITY IMPACTS
AND THE ALTERNATIVE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. WHICH
ALLOWS MANY OF OUR SMALLER
SCALE- PRODUCERS TO BE ABLE TO
CONVERT BACK RICH NUTRIENT
SOURCE INTO COMPOST AND OTHER
MINORITIES PRODUCTS- AND- THAT
PROGRAM HAS HAD OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE JERRY
FAMILIES PARTICIPATE. OVER THE
LIFETIME OF THE PROGRAM WE
CALCULATE THAT THERE'S BEEN A
TOTAL GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
OF ABOUT TWO POINT THREE
MILLION METRIC TONS AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING HAPPY
TOGETHER. IN PARTNERSHIP. I'M
MAYBE SOMEBODY FROM CAL RECYCLE
ENOUGH SEX THE DIRECTOR
WAGNER'S ERE BUT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT WASTE DIVERSION WE HAVE
BEEN A WAVE CAL FIRE HERE WHO'S
GOT WOULD WAYS WE'VE GOT
AGRICULTURE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
AGRICULTURE WAYS. URBAN PEOPLE
HAVE URBAN WASTE AND THAT TERRY
PEOPLE HAVEN'T JERRY WAYS IS
THERE ARE. OPPORTUNITIES ON THE
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE
FOR- WASTE DIVERSION TED TO GET
SOME OF THESE COUNTIES AND
CITIES WHO. HAVEN'T IMPLEMENTED
ANY OF THE- S. B. THIRTY
EIGHTY. OF GO IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS OF JUST SIT BY WHERE THEY-
WE MAY. BRING SOME OF THESE YOU
KNOW AND ON THE STEAM OF HAPPY
TOGETHER CAN WE BRING SOME OF
THESE WASTE PRODUCER METHANE
EMITTERS TOGETHER. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION APPRECIATE
THAT I THINK YOU KNOW POWER
THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE RAGS
IN THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY-
AFTER MANY MANY WORKSHOPS WITH
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS SO I AM VERY
OPTIMISTIC THAT. WE AND WORKING
WITH OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THE L. A.'S. AT THE LANDFILLS
AND THEN OUR PARTNERS AT CDFA
AND NATURAL RESOURCES ON COMING
UP WITH SOME CREATIVE SOLUTIONS
FOR THE DIFFERENT REGIONS OF
CALIFORNIA ON HOW TO DEAL WITH
THEIR ORGANICS WASTE. AND WE'VE
SEEN A LOT OF GOOD WORK AND A
LOT OF CREATIVITY ACROSS THE
STATE AND DIFFERENT TYPES OF
JURISDICTIONS. AND WE CONTINUE
THAT PARTNERSHIP- ADDITIONALLY
OUR CYCLE HAS DEVELOPED.
DIFFERENT TYPES OF TOOLS TO
HELP LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. AND
ESTABLISH THEIR ORDINANCES AND
FIGURE OUT THE PROCUREMENT
REQUIREMENTS AND SO WE CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM BUT YES I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE I THINK THAT
IN THE THEME I'M HAPPY TOGETHER
THERE IS A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY
HERE. AND TO WORK TOGETHER TO
ACHIEVE OUR SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT. REDUCTION. GOAL BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. BOB I HAVE
A FOLLOW. I CENTER DOLLY SO
WANTED TO AYE OPPOSED SKEWS ME
I'VE THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE FOR
THE REASON THAT. THE ONE SIZE
FITS ALL FOR CALIFORNIA IS VERY
DIFFICULT IN A DISTRICT. LIKE
MINE THAT IS IT WOULD COST IT
WOULD HAVE MORE OF AN IMPACT ON
THE ENVIRONMENT DESPITE THE
TRANSPORTATION OF MOVING ALL
THESE. RECYCLABLES OR OR
ORGANICS AROUND AND SO ARE
OTHER EXERT A FOCUS ON LOOKING
AT TRYING TO DO SOMETHING- IN
THE LOCAL LOCALITIES IN
DISTRICTS SUCH AS MINE WHAT WE
HAVE- YOU KNOW LOOKS VERY SMALL
COMMUNITY SPREAD. VERY FAR
APART. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I THINK THAT IS ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT IS I'M- AYE SO
BEAUTIFUL ABOUT SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE IS IT REALLY
LEAVES. THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THE OPPORTUNITIES TO DEVISE A
PLAN FOR HOW BEST TO MEET THESE
OBJECTIVES THE 75% REDUCTION
GOAL IS A STATE WIDE GOAL IT
ISN'T. YOUR SECTION BY
JURISDICTION SO WE'RE NOT
LOOKING TO HOLD EVERY
JURISDICTION. TO A 75%
REDUCTION OF THEIR ORGANICS
WHAT WE ARE LOOKING FOR IS
COMPLIANCE WITH THE
REGULATIONS. THAT HAVE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
OPTIONS FOR HOW THEY COME INTO
COMPLIANCE SO IT'S REALLY NICE
TO BE- AND THEN YOU THAT. FAST
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL REGIONS. AND
THAT'S WHY I SAID THAT WORKING
TOGETHER TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
GOAL IS SO IMPORTANT THAT THE
ONLY WAY WE'RE GOING TO GET
275% IS THAT WE ARE ALL WORKING
TOWARDS COMPLIANCE TOGETHER.
SMALL AND LARGE AND IN A WAY
THAT WORKS FOR THAT
JURISDICTION I ABSOLUTELY AGREE
THAT WE SHOULD BE PUTTING IN
PLACE SYSTEMS. THAT AND BACK
CREATE AND NEW OR DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENTAL HARM TO ADDRESS
THOSE ENVIRONMENTAL HARM THAT
THIS LEGISLATION IS MEANT TO
ADDRESS. AND SO YES VERY MUCH
WORKING WHEN THE SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS LEARNERS
JURISDICTIONS FIGURE OUT WHAT
WORKS BEST FOR THEM. THANK YOU-
WE HAVE DODD CHIEF PORTER ON
AND I WAS I KNOW WE TOOK SOME
EARLY ACTION ON OUR HEALTHY. OF
FOR SOME REASON ARE HEALTHY AND
RESILIENT FORCE AND THERE AND
NOW WE HAVE- TWO HUNDRED
MILLION HERE CAN YOU GIVE US AN
UPDATE WHY HAVE YOU ON. WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND IS IT.
IS IT GOOD THINGS OR BAD THINGS.
I WE HAVE A RED FLAG ALERTS
THAT'D BE THAT FOR TWO
GENERALLY ON THE PER. THANK YOU
RIGHT CHAIRED SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE HE- TOM PORTER CALIFORNIA
DIRECTOR. AND I II- WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO HAVE MY OUR
EXPERTS SPEAK TO THAT SO
ANGELES IS AVAILABLE. AND WILL
ADDRESS THAT SPECIFICALLY. ALSO
DANIEL BRANDT. IS ON THE LINE
AS WELL. ANGIE. GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING I'M I APOLOGIZE BUT
I'VE MISSED THE SPECIFIC
QUESTION WOULD IT BE POSSIBLE
TO REPEAT WHAT WE HAVE THERE'S
TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN HERE FOR
CAP AND TRADE FOR THAT- HEALTHY
AND RESILIENT FORCE BUT WE TOOK
SOME EARLY ACTION IN APRIL OF A
MONTH AGO AND I WAS WONDERING
WHAT IS HAPPENING ON THE GROUND
OR IS. HOW IS THAT. RULING OUT.
I GUESS. THANK YOU SO MUCH SO
WITH THE EARLY ACTION FUNDING
THEIR NUMBER OF PROGRAMS THAT-
THAT CAL FIRE IS RECEIVING.
FUNDING FOR. ALL OF THEM HAVE
MOVED FORWARD AND PLANS TO
SPEND THE FUNDS AND SEVERAL OF
THEM HAVE. GOTTEN FUNDING INTO
PARTNERS HANDS- SPECIFICALLY BE
FORCED HEALTH GRANT PROGRAM-
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR MY CAMERA
LAYING HERE. THE FIRST UPGRADE
PROGRAM- HAS BEEN MOVING- WITH-
PROJECTS THAT WERE UNABLE TO BE
FUNDED IN PRIOR YEARS DUE TO
LACK OF FUNDING. AND ARE
EXECUTING GRANT AGREEMENTS WITH
THOSE PARTNERS ALSO OUR UNIT
FIRE- OUR UNITS ARE WORKING A
FIRE PREVENTION PROJECTS AND
THEY- HAVE SUCCESSFULLY BEEN
COMPLETING WORK. ON OVER THE
PAST MONTHS. WE ARE ALSO
WORKING ON GETTING FUNDS INTO
CONTRACTS FOR ADDITIONAL WORK
ENHANCING SOME EXISTING
PROJECTS AND BRINGING IN. NEW
PROJECTS. OTHER EARLY ACTION
FUNDING HAS BEEN REALLY
CRITICAL FOR HELPING US- TO HIT
THE GROUND RUNNING. THROUGH
THROUGH MANY OF OUR PROGRAMS.
OKAY DON'T SEE ANY I GUESS THE
OTHER THE OTHER QUESTION WE SEE
THE SENATE PLAN FOR AT LEAST
ONE YEAR PULLS OUT THE S. R. A
FEE- AND TAKES THAT FROM OTHER
SOURCES. IS JUST SO EVERYBODY'S
CLEAR IT I THINK EVERY
UNDERSTANDS IT'S NOT CHANGING
THE PROGRAM OR NOT CHANGING THE
WORK PLAN THAT YOU FOLKS HAVE
FOR ESPECIALLY PEOPLE OF ONE IF
ANYBODY CAN SELL PROPERTY AND
THE- THE MOVIE NOW NOWADAYS.
BUT BUT IT'S JUST IT'S JUST A
FUNDING MECHANISM SO THAT SOME.
ONCE AGAIN TRYING TO LOOK AT
CARBON REDUCTION- EXPENDITURES
AT LEAST FOR A YEAR RIGHT-
LET'S SEE. FINANCE I HAVEN'T
CHIPPED IN WITH FINANCES IS
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT FROM THE
JANUARY PROPOSAL- NOT THAT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF THINGS
HAPPENING TO ME REVISED WE GOT
THAT MAY CAP AND TRADE AUCTION
A LOT OF THINGS HAPPENING.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COMMENT
MISTER. Z. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHERILUS HERE
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE'VE NOT HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW THE SENATE'S PROPOSED
CARPENTRY PLAN A DETAIL YEAH WE
APPRECIATE HEARING YUR
COMMENTS THIS MORNING AND THE
SENATE HOLDING THE ISSUE OPEN
AND- AS YOU SIDE WILL BE
RELEASING THE MAYOR VERSION
LATER THIS WEEK AND YOU LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
AFTER THAT. OKAY YEAH GOOD
WE'RE WE'RE- PARTICULARLY- YOU
KNOW WE THINK THAT THE- LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
ALTHOUGH IT DOESN'T COME UNDER
THIS. SIX SEVENTEEN UMBRELLA
WAS VERY POPULAR. IS AT LEAST
THE DATA THAT WE READ. OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AS THE EMISSIONS
FROM OUR BUILDINGS PARTICULAR
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS- IS VERY IMPORTANT.
AND YOU KNOW WE'D LIKE TO. TO
HAVE THE ADMINISTRATION TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT END OF NOTE. AS
YOU CAN SEE SOME OF THESE. SOME
OF THESE PROGRAMS. ARE TRIED
AND TRUE THAT ARE- YOU KNOW.
THE WOOD STOVE REPLACEMENT THAT
DIDN'T GET ANY MONEY BUT WE
THINK WHAT WE DON'T PUT IT
UNDER THE BANNER OF EQUITY
PROGRAMS WE THINK THAT IT. IT
HAS THE FULL WALKS LIKE A DUCK
TALKS LIKE A DUCK AND HAS ALL
THAT INTO SHOULD THE PEOPLE
LOOK AT- LET'S SAY THE SENATOR
STERN YOU HAVE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I JUST SINCE
WE ACHIEVED PORTER ON AYE I
WANTED A. EXTEND MY
APPRECIATION- FOR FOLLOWING
THROUGH ON. THE IMPORTANT
DIRECTION IN OUR EARLY ACTION
FUNDING PLAN NOT JUST ABOUT-
WHERE THE MONEY MOVES BUT HOW
IT'S INVESTED IN THAT KIND OF
OUTREACH THAT'S BEING DONE- TO
ADD DIVERSE REGIONS AROUND THE
STATE SO SINCERELY APPRECIATE
THAT AND I GUESS I JUST WANTED
TO ASK. DO YOUR POINT MISTER
CHAIR IT'S A THOUGHT THAT I
WANTED TO PUT ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RADAR I DON'T
KNOW. I DON'T KNOW HOW IT FITS
TOGETHER BUT- THE LINK BETWEEN
THE RICH WINTERIZATION AND OUR
AND OUR SORT OF EFFICIENCY
PROGRAMS AND THE HOME HARDENING
SIDE OF THINGS. AND WHETHER
THERE ARE ANY OPPORTUNITIES
FORM FOR LEVERAGING MULTIPLE
FUNDING STREAMS GOING FORWARD I
KNOW WE ONLY HAVE LIMITED-
FUNDS AVAILABLE I NOTICED YOU
KNOW IN OUR IN THE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE INSPECTION PLAN YOU WERE
GONNA HIT WHAT TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND I THINK IN. OUR
PROPOSAL. JUST FOR THE
INSPECTION SIDE- AND YOU KNOW
AS YOU ALL HAVE STATED THIS IS
A THAT THAT. THE SIZE OF THE
HARDENING CHALLENGE IS VERY
LARGE RIGHT NOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLAR A YEAR
ESTIMATE- SO ARE THERE ANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEVERAGE
MULTIPLE FUNDING STREAMS IN
MULTIPLE PROGRAMS HERE SO IF
YOU HAVE. LOW INCOME. RESIDENTS
WHO NEEDS WEATHER STRIPPING ON
THEIR HOME. THEY ALSO WITH THAT
WEATHER STRIPPING YOU COULD DO
GAS GETTING IN YOUR GARAGE. OR
WHILE YOU'RE YOU KNOW MAKING
SURE EMBERS CAN'T GET THROUGH
YOUR WINDOWS CAN YOU- CAN YOU
OFF THE SAME TIME THAT RETROFIT
ALSO LOOK AT. THE FIRE
HARDENING OPPORTUNITIES-
GRANTED IT'LL BE AS A SUBSET OF
THAT POPULATION BUT I JUST.
WANTED TO RAISE IT FOR THE-
YEAH COMMITTEE OR THE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S. JUST AS A
POTENTIAL ECONOMY OF SCALE
BECAUSE WE KNOW ALSO THERE'S
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL DOLLARS IN
THAT SPACE AS WELL- ENDING
POTENTIALLY SO- SOMETHING TO
CONSIDER BUT ON THE WHOLE
MISTER CHAIR I'M- YEAH AT A- IN
THE DISCUSSION THUS FAR AND-
YEAH I LOOK FORWARD TO GOING
BIG NO DATE. ANYONE ON THE
ADMINISTRATION LIKE TO COMMENT.
WELL I CAN I CAN START- IN
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN VERY
FOR YOUR QUESTION AND YOUR-
YOUR THOUGHTFUL WORDS THAT
WILDFIRE OR- THIS LAST WEEKEND
AND- CALABASAS RIGHT TO THIS
AND- I THINK. WE ARE LOOKING AT
ALL ASPECTS OF HOME GARDENING
IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS NEW FOR
US- TO DEVELOP A PROGRAM. THAT
IS- LOOKING AT THAT ELEMENT-
AND AS YOU'RE AWARE TRULY AREAS
LIKE THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE OUR
EFFORTS THAT WE DO THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IS- HOMEOWNERS-
RESPONSIBILITY BUT THERE ARE-
AREAS WHERE- PARTICULARLY LOW
INCOME OR PEOPLE OF NEED ARE
CAN BENEFIT FROM. MORE OF A
COMMUNITY WIDE APPROACH WE'RE
LOOKING AT THOSE OPPORTUNITIES-
AS WELL AS DOING THE EDUCATION
TO ALL WHERE ALL HOMEOWNERS.
BUT TO THE LEVERAGING OF
FEDERAL FUNDS AND OTHER FUNDS
THAT MIGHT BE AVAILABLE BOTH
LOCALLY AND THROUGH- NONPROFIT-
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THAT WE
CAN AND WILL BE LOOKING AT AS
OPPORTUNITIES. OF COURSE WE'RE
WORKING WITH CALLOW YES ON THE
THEME OF FUNDS TO HOPEFULLY
FIND A WAY TO. LEVERAGE OUR THE
DOLLARS ARE COMING IN FROM
STATE COFFERS AND- I THINK I'M
GOING TO ALLOW IT DANIEL BROUGH
LATCHES SPEAK SPECIFICALLY ON
HOW THIS IS DONE DEALING WITH
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE FOR
FIRE PREVENTION AND THE GRANT
PROGRAM. IS FUNDED THROUGH THIS
EFFORT. UNDER THAT PROGRAM AS
WELL DANIEL. THANK YOU CHIEF
AND- GOOD MORNING. CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
IMPLANT ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH CAL FIRE- FIRST I
JUST WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THANKS TO THE EARLY ACTION OF
MONEY THAT YOU DID PUT FORWARD-
WE HAVE BEEN REALLY- MOVING
FORWARD AT A FAST PACE WORKING
WITH CALLAWAY HAS TO BUILD HE
STRUCTURE. TO YOUR QUESTION-
CENTER IN YOUR POINT- LEVER ANY
PROGRAM WE CAN TO BE NOT ONLY
IF IT'S BUT HELL US. INTO THE
BILL TO HARD HOMES HIS
ABSOLUTELY SO WE CONTINUE TO
WORK AT I'LL NOTE WE ARE
BRINGING OTHER DEPARTMENTS
LIKE- EACH CD HOUSING TO MEET
OF ELEMENT THE TRYING TO
LEVERAGE EFFORTS THEY'RE DOING
I AM MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE-
NOT ONLY BE AN EFFICIENT NOT
ONLY THAT WERE STREAMLINING BUT
THAT WORRY ABOUT REALLY ABLE TO
MAXIMIZE THIS PROGRAM AND SO. I
THINK YOUR YOUR POINT ABOUT THE
WEATHER IS ATION- PROGRAM WITH
OUR SISTER AGENCY IS SPOT ON
AND WE WILL DEFINITELY JUMP
INTO THE LOOKING THAT AND THEN
BACK TO. REPORTERS COMMENT
ABOUT THE OVERALL FIRE
PREVENTION GRANT FUNDING- WE'RE
ONLY ABOUT A WEEK AWAY FROM
CLOSING OR APPLICATION PERIOD
AND AGAIN- THANK YOU TO THE
EARLY ACTION DOLLARS THAT YOU
PUT FORWARD WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE
TO QUICKLY- RANK BILLS. AND GET
MONEY OUT ON THE GROUND IN A
VERY FAST PACED I IN MONTHS I
HAD A WHERE WE WOULD HAVE BEEN
IF THERE WASN'T EARLY ACTION
SO- AGAIN A LOT OF GOOD WORK
ABOUT TO HAPPEN AND- LOOKING
FORWARD TO REPORTING BACK TO
YOU THE SUCCESSES. AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM HOME HARDING- BUT
AS WELL THE FIRE BRIDGE RAMP
PROGRAM. BOB FOLLOWS ONE.
SINISTER LEVINE ESE. JUST JUST
ONE FINAL FOLLOW POINT FOR
CONSIDERATION AND- ONE MORE
DOVE TAILING I GUESS THAT I'M
I'M I'M TRYING TO THINK ABOUT
AS WE AS WE SORT OF WORK I'M
SORT OF MULTI JURISDICTIONAL
BASIS AND ALSO AS YOU RIGHTLY
POINT OUT FOR LEVERAGE PRIVATE
HOMEOWNERS- I THINK OF MY
DISTRICT THE PRETTY DIVERSE
COMMUNITY IN TERMS INCOME-
CERTAIN PARTS. THAT ARE UNIQUE
PEOPLE LIVING IN MOBILE HOMES-
IN ON FIXED INCOME AND OTHER
PARTS IN A MULTI MILLION DOLLAR
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR MANSIONS-
YOU KNOW THERE'S A THERE'S A
HUGE RANGE AND SO I THINK WE'RE
SMART TO BE PUSHING ON PRIVATE
HOMEOWNER. ACTION AND I GUESS I
JUST. BE INSURANCE SIDE OF
THINGS SEEMS LIKE SUCH AN
IMPORTANT DRIVER FOR THAT AND
THAT'S IN THE CENTER REQUIRE
MYSELF I'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR
A WHILE TRYING TO GET
RECOGNITION FOR THOSE EFFORTS
TAKEN BY HOMEOWNERS THAT THEY
HAVE AN INCENTIVE TO HOLD ON TO
THEIR INSURANCE IF THEY
UNDERTAKE CARTONING MEASURES ON
THEIR OWN TIME BUT THAT HELPS
THEM ACTUALLY YOU KNOW KEEP
THEIR- THEIR AT THEIR COSTS
DOWN. ON AN ANNUAL BASIS SO
THEY DON'T GET ACTUALLY PRICED
OUT OF THEIR OWN HOME SO- I
WANTED ALSO THROW OUT THERE AND
I'LL BE FOLLOWING UP- AS THE AS
THIS BUDGET. MOVES THROUGH THE
PROCESS BUT- I LEADING THE FARM
ENSURE IS WELL. AND I THINK CD
I CAN ACTUALLY PLAY A REALLY
IMPORTANT ROLE- IN TERMS OF.
EXPEDITING THE AUDIT AND
INSPECTION PROCESS AND REALLY
TRYING TO COME UP WITH THE
CERTIFICATION THAT IS GOING TO
ALLOW FOR- IT INCENTIVE THAT
DOESN'T REQUIRE PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES. SO JUST TRYING TO
CREATE STANDARDIZATION SO I'M
HOPING THAT AS WE GO FORWARD
THIS. WILDFIRE PACKAGE BOTH IN
THE- FIRE PACKAGE AS WELL AS
WHAT'S BEFORE US HERE TODAY
THAT. THAT WEEK WE TAKE A LOOK
AT WHAT WE CAN DO WITH CDI. AND
HOW TO LEVERAGE THEIR EXPERTISE
ON THE RISK PROFILES AND THE
MODELING THAT THEY USE IN THE
INDUSTRY EXPERTISE THIS OUT
THERE- AND REALLY TRYING TO.
DICTATE TRIGGER THAT PRIVATE
CAPITAL INTO THE SPACE TO DO SO
THANKS FOR THE INTELLIGENCE ON
THIS PIECE MISTER CHAIR AND
AGAIN. SINCERE THANKS TO THE
CHIEF PORTER AND FOR EVERYONE
FOR SHOWING UP AND WORKING
THROUGH THESE ISSUES- YOU KNOW
I KNOW WE'VE GOT A DEADLINE
COMING UP I'M HOPING THAT THE
COMMUNITIES CAN. GET CREATIVE
AND COORDINATED QUICKLY ENOUGH
BUT THE I ALSO HOPE THAT. IF WE
CAN HIT IT- YOU KNOW HERE IN
MAY DAY BUT THERE WILL BE THIS
ONGOING STRAIN SO THAT AS
PEOPLE WAKE UP TO THIS AND ALL
THIS OUT REACH STARTS TO PAY
OFF THAT. WOULD BE ABLE TO- AT
THE MEET THE TO MEET THE
COMMUNITY IN RIGHT SO THANKS A
LOT. HUNDRED DOLLARS. THANK YOU
I WANT TO JUST. TAKE A- STERN'S
CO AND USE IT AS- BECAUSE-
TALKING. EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN MY COMMUNITY SO
THAT REPORTER- DOCTOR PORTER I
WAS WONDERING- ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WERE FACED
WITH. IS THAT WE HAVE THE LOCAL
FOR THE MAYBE THE CITY FIRE
DEPARTMENT OR THE COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT AND WE HAVE CAL FIRE
WE HAVE INSURANCE ISSUES IN ALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND THERE
IS REALLY NO HAS BEEN KNOWN
BUDDY THAT ACTUALLY IS AT LEAST
TO MY KNOWLEDGE AND I THINK
PART OF THIS INSPECTION PROCESS
IT SHOULD BE WE ACTUALLY GET A
CERTIFICATE THAT SAYS HEY THIS
LANDOWNER HAS MET THE CRITERIA
SO THEY CAN TAKE THAT. TO THEIR
INSURANCE COMPANY AND SAY HEY
WE'VE DONE HOME HARDENING WE'VE
HAVE ARE DEFENSIBLE SPACE- IS
THAT CAN YOU COMMENT MAYBE ON
HOW THAT WOULD LOOK THEM AND
THAT WHICH WHICH AGENCY
ACTUALLY HAS THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO. GO OUT AND INSPECT AND
GIVE A CERTIFICATE TO THE
LANDOWNER THAT THAT THEY'VE
DONE THEIR JOB ON DOING THE
BEST THEY CAN AND IN THE PART
OF THE STATE THAT THEY LIVE IN.
AND THEIR ENVIRONMENT TO KEEP
THEIR PROPERTY AND THEMSELVES
SAFE. SENATOR DOLLY THAT'S A
THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION AND
THAT WHILE HOME HARDENING IS
PART OF THE ANSWER- IT IS NEW
SO IT IS NOT A PART OF- KIND OF
THE BROADER. PERSPECTIVES YET
IT WILL BE AS WE START MOVING
FORWARD- IN THIS SPACE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE HOWEVER IS
SOMETHING THAT- IS IT'S A
COMPLIANCE. PROGRAM AND WHILE
WE DON'T- I HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO. INSPIRE INSPECT EVERY HOME
IN THE STATE RESPONSIBILITY
AREA AND THAT'S WHAT I'M I'M
REPRESENTING- WE DO TRY TO GET
TO A ROUGHLY- EVERY PROPERTY
WITH. WITH IN A THREE YEAR
CYCLE. AND SO IS SO THERE ARE
THERE IS SOME SOME ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT THERE AND
CERTIFICATION- OF HOMES THAT
ARE. MEETING THEIR DEFENSIBLE
SPACE- IS SOMETHING THAT- THAT
CAN BE DONE- WE'VE CONSIDERED
AND CONTINUE TO LOOK AT SELF
CERTIFICATION. POSSIBILITIES IN
THAT SPACE AS WELL AS-
COMPLIANCE INSPECTIONS THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO. SO THERE
THERE IS ROOM TO WORK TO WORK
FORWARD IN THAT SPACE I THINK-
CHEAPER LAST MENTIONED. AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE-
MANY OF INSURANCEON ALL THESE
IS. ARE GOING FORWARD AND WE DO
SEE THAT THERE IS VALUE IN AND-
FINING US WHERE INSURANCE-
REDUCTION IN COSTS FOR LAND
OWNERS BASED ON THEIR THEIR
COMPLIANCE IS A PLACE WHERE WE
CAN LEVERAGE FORWARD. ALL OF
THE EFFORTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT HERE. SO
OPPORTUNITIES DEFINITELY FOR-
INCREASE THERE I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE OF THAT THAT I
HIGHLIGHTED WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE STATE RESPONSIBILITY
AREA. THERE'S ALSO A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF WHAT
WHAT YOU MENTIONED IN THOSE
THOSE LOCAL FIRE DEPARTMENT-
SPACES- WHERE WERE IN. AREAS
THAT ARE LOCAL RESPONSIBILITY
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSIBILITY- BUT- ALL OF
THOSE ARE KIND OF FIRE SAFETY
REGULATIONS ARE BEING
COORDINATED AND SOME OF THAT-
THE FIRE SAFE BREAKS THAT ARE
COMING FORWARD THROUGH THE-
BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION WILL ALSO BE
ADDRESSED. EVEN INTO THOSE
LOCAL RESPONSIBILITY AREAS AND
GIVE US SOME SOME- PLACES TO-
KIND OF WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT'S HAPPENING.
ACROSS THE BOARD. I'M A VERY
MERGING KERR TO. HEAR THAT YOU
KNOW A LOT OF IT IS JUST THAT.
DISTANCE EDUCATION AT THE AT
THE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
THAT THAT THEY CAN DO THE WORK
OURSELVES THEY CAN DO THE
MANAGEMENT THEMSELVES- AND SO
THAT'S IT THAT'S KEY I THINK IT
CROSSED. ALL ALL JURISDICTIONS.
AND SOMEHOW WE NEED TO GET. ALL
OF THEM WORKING TOGETHER COME
UP WITH A PROGRAM THAT. ALLOWS
THEM TO GET A CERTIFICATE THAT
SAYS THEY'VE ACTUALLY COMPLETED
THE WORK AND THERE'S- A IS
SIGNED OFF SO THEY CAN ACTUALLY
TAKE IT TO THEIR- INSURANCE
COMPANY BECAUSE- AT THE END OF
THE DAY. WHAT THEY'RE PAYING
FOR INSURANCE IN MANY CASES
THEY GET HOME HARDEN THEIR
HOUSE WITH THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THEY'RE SPENDING ON INSURANCE
TO KEEP THEIR INSURANCE THEIR
HOUSES INSURED. ONE LAST
COMMENT I KNOW THAT WERE. AS WE
HAVE THE DIRECTOR HERE- IN THIS
JUST A COMMENT- I KNOW THAT SB
NINE OH ONE WE WE'RE ALLOCATING
TO. THE TO HONOR MILLION YEAR I
JUST WANTED TO. MAKE SURE TO
FOCUS TO. TO DO BIOMASS
UTILIZATION THAT'S ONE OF THE-
I THINK FOR MOST OF THE STATE
IS YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING
WITH ALL THIS MATERIAL AND HOW
WE CAN. RE DIRECT THAT AND COME
UP WITH OTHER ALTERNATIVES I
JUST WANT THAT TO. BE ON YOUR
RADAR SOMETHING THAT- I KNOW
I'M FOCUSED ON AND MANY OTHERS
IN THE STATE THAT. OF OTHER
WAYS TO USE THAT MATERIAL- TO.
AFFECTIVELY STORE THAT CARBON
SO A JUST A NOTE FOR THAT. AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR- THE
INFORMATION YOU PROVIDED US
HERE TODAY. YEAH I REALIZED
DON'T HAVE OPR. WE DON'T HAVE
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
HERE BUT WHERE THERE IS. SOME
AT LEAST AN INVESTMENT THAT THE
SENATE HAS THAT THAT'S LIKE TO.
LET EVERYBODY TALK. TAGS OR
EIGHT. TRY TO DIGEST HIS SET ON
CLIMATE RESEARCH AND ENERGY
RESEARCH AND- PLANNING CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCY
PROGRAM AND THEN THESE SHOVEL
READY PROJECT DURING THE DAY
HOPEFULLY CROSSETT GO ACROSS
ALL JURISDICTIONS WHETHER IT'S
IN THE AG MARKET OR THE
FORESTRY MARKET OR NATURAL
RESOURCES AND THINGS LIKE THAT
THERE'S- THERE'S IT'S ONE THING
I KNOW THERE'S A BIG INVESTMENT
BY THE MINISTRATION ON. SIX ONE
SEVEN AND TO HAVE PEOPLE COME
TOGETHER BUT THERE'S NOTHING
LIKE A WOOD STOVE CLICHE A
PICTURE'S WORTH A THOUSAND
WORDS AND I KNOW THAT EVERYBODY
LIKES TO GET TOGETHER AND TALK
ABOUT IT BUT THE SEE THE
PROJECT WORKING IT HAS AN
ADVANTAGE DEMONSTRATED AND WE
BRING IN PLANNING. OUR FOLKS
SAID HAZARD- THE POTENTIAL TO
REALLY HELP US REDUCE THE
CARBON SELF I DON'T KNOW IF.
ANYBODY ON THE SPOT BUT THERE
IS THOSE THOSE CATEGORIES THERE
THAT THEY'RE PART UNDER
ANYBODY'S PARTICULAR
JURISDICTION BECAUSE IT SAYS
THIS IS THE INTEGRATED OFFICE
OF PLANNING RESEARCH BUT
EVERYBODY GETS A CHANCE TO COME
IN WITH THEIR RESILIENCY
PROGRAM OR THEIR- PILOT PROGRAM
THIS COULD EFFECTIVELY SHOW HOW
WE REDUCE CARBON SPHERES SO-
DASHES. THIS IS IN THERE. PART
OF OUR DISCUSS- AND THAT'S THAT
IS ANYBODY DID ASK FINANCE
ALREADY REJECTED FOR A DEBT AND
GET US FINANCE FINANCES IS
COMMON SO IF ANYBODY DOESN'T.
SINISTERLY EVER HAD UP OR IS
THAT YEAH OKAY. I JUST WANTED
TO I GUESS APPLAUD YOU FOR.
KEEPING RESEARCH ALIVE YEAR
AFTER YEAR- THIS ISN'T THE
FIRST TIME. BUT HEY IT'S THIS
WON'T SIT ON A SHELF I AM
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL AND I AND I DID WANT
TO TRY TO GET. L. A. ALWAYS
TAKE ON. YES HOW HOW THIS
RESEARCH. COULD WILL BE
OPERATIONALIZED POTENTIALLY
LIKE WHERE WHERE'D WHERE WE CAN
REALLY START TO IDENTIFY THE
VALUE ADD AS IT AS AN EXAMPLE
SINCE WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE
CHIEF HERE AND- AND OUR FIRE
SIDE OF THINGS- FROM AN
EMERGENCY. PLANNING PERSPECTIVE
CALIFORNIA YES ARE ARE VERY
BUSY AGENCIES AND IN SOME WAYS.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU TALK TO- YES
THE STATE LEVEL OR EVEN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. THEY DON'T HAVE IN
HOUSE WHEN THEY DO A RISK
MAPPING PROJECT WHEN THEY LOOK
IT'S A FIRE RISK IN AN AREA
THAT WOULD TO A CONSULTANT AND-
PUT BACK TOGETHER TECHNICALLY
FOR A COUNTY OR CITY AND GATHER
THAT DATA. BUT THE BUT THE LONG
TERM PERSONNEL. ACTUALLY KNOWS
WHERE THOSE AT RISK COMMUNITIES
ARE WHEN A BAD THING HAPPENS
LIKE A FIRE AND CAN BE THERE IN
INCIDENT COMMAND WITH SORT OF
OPERATIONALIZED RESEARCH IF YOU
WILL- IT SEEMS TO ME A REALLY.
EXCITING SYNTHESIS OF WHAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE PUTTING FORWARD
HERE WHERE AND YOU CAN YOU CAN
APPLY THAT ON A NUMBER OF OTHER
OF THE RESILIENCY FRONTS RIGHT
IT'S NOT JUST WILD FIRE USED AS
AN EXAMPLE BUT- TO HAVE. THIS
SORT OF BUT CLIMATE RISK
MODELING BUILDING NOT JUST A
LONG TERM LAND USE PLANNING.
BUT THE SHORT TERM. CLIMATE
DISASTER. PRE HAZARD. IF YOU
WILL RIGHT IF WE CAN DO THAT
CREE HAZARD MITIGATION PLANNING
AND GETTING INTO GENERAL PLANS.
AND THE SORT OF GOVERNING
DOCUMENTS OF HAZARD MANAGEMENT
LOCALLY. WE'RE GONNA END UP
SAVING LIVES THIS RESEARCH I
MEAN I SO I JUST I DON'T MEAN
TO INDULGE TOO MUCH IN THAT
POINT BUT I THINK THAT'S WHAT
THE CLIMATE ASSESSMENT ITSELF
IN DOING THIS FIFTH VERSION. I
THINK THAT THAT'S WHAT THE
SIDECAR POSITIONS IN LOCAL
RESILIENCY OFFICERS CAN DO BUT
I DIDN'T KNOW IF YOU'VE GIVEN
THAT ANY THOUGHT OF. HOW
PLANNING ACTUALLY ISN'T JUST
PLANNING BUT IN THE IN IN THE
KIND OF. PLANNING AND RESEARCH
PROPOSAL THAT THE SENATE PUT
FORWARD. YOU SEE THE ABILITY
FOR PLANNING TO BECOME
LIFESAVING TO. DOWNPOUR I'M NOT
TOO FAR DOWN WILL. YEAH I
THINK- I THINK IT'S A GREAT
KIND OF AREA OF THIS KIND OF
FOCUS AND QUESTIONING
UNFORTUNATELY KIND OF ONE OF
OUR COLLEAGUES REGULATORS WAS
WORK A LOT ON KIND OF YOU KNOW
CLIMATE RESILIENCY AND
ADAPTATION KIND OF ISN'T ON THE
CALL RIGHT NOW BUT I THINK. AT
A HIGH LEVEL- YEAH I THINK KIND
OF THE ISSUES AROUND JUST KIND
OF BETTER UNDERSTANDING- AND
SORT OF PLANNING WHAT THE RISKS
ARE WHERE THEY ARE AND HOW TO
POSITION RESOURCES HOW TO SORT
OF INVEST RESOURCES IN A WAY TO
KIND OF. REDUCE THAT RISK MOST
EFFECTIVELY IS AN ISSUE THAT I
KNOW IT HIGHLIGHTED A LOT IN
THE WILDFIRE SPACE JUST
DIFFERENT SORT OF ALL THE
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT ARE GOING
ON BUT I THINK IT SORT OF AS
YOU POINT OUT IT KIND OF CUTS
ACROSS A LOT OF DIFFERENT AREAS
AND SO. I THINK RESEARCH AND
GENERAL- JUST KIND OF GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF- YOU
WHERE THE RISKS ARE ON KIND OF
ADAPTATION CITING THE
RESILIENCY SIDE AS WELL AS ON
THE MITIGATION SIDE AND KIND OF
WHAT WE'RE GETTING FOR OUR OUR
RESOURCES AND KIND OF OUR
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS- I KNOW WE
HIGHLIGHTED A LOT IN THE PAST
IS KIND OF AN AREA OF THIS.
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE TO KIND OF
FOCUS RESOURCES ON BECAUSE IN
THE END YOU'RE GONNA YOU KNOW
YOU YOU OF THE LEGISLATURE
GOING TO BE MAKING A LOT OF A
POLICY DECISIONS GOING FORWARD
ABOUT KIND OF HOW DO AND INVEST
RESOURCES IN FUTURE YEARS OUT
IT WOULD KNOW WHICH POLICIES
AND PROGRAMS TO ADOPT AND- JUST
THE MORE INFORMATION WE HAVE
ABOUT. HOW TO INVEST THOSE IN
THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY AND KIND
OF YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
STRATEGIES ARE KIND OF MOST
EFFECTIVE AT ACHIEVING BOTH OF
THOSE GOALS ON CERTAIN
MITIGATION ADAPTATION SIDE IS
REALLY GOING TO HELP- YOU THE
LEGISLATURE CERTAIN AND MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS AROUND THOSE
ISSUES SO MY COLLEAGUE BRIAN
BROWN IS ALSO ON THE CALL YOU
MIGHT HAVE IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING
ELSE TO SORT OF TIME AND WAY
AND I'M- YOU CAN DO THAT BUT I
THINK KIND OF THE FOCUS ON SORT
OF RESEARCH. OR SOMETHING THAT
I THINK WE GENERALLY SUPPORT OF
A LOT THE PAST. TO HELP INFORM
DECISIONS. YEAH I APPRECIATE
THAT I KNOW MISTER BROWN AS A
COMMENT BUT- AS A FINAL. OF
POINT OF CLEAR. SINCE WE HAVE.
FIRE I KNOW WE GAVE. LANGUAGE
THAT THERE. A DIRECT TO. WITH
FIRE FROM. PROGRAM. LOCALS ARE
ABLE TO SORT OF. PUSH BACK DATA
UP. AND IN THEORY WE CAN HAVE.
SORT OF SOME. OF ASSESS. THAT
AS A FISCAL- X. ELEMENT SEVEN
WHAT WHERE WERE APPROPRIATE
FIRE FROM. YOU KNOW WE KNOW
WE'RE HITTING THE PEOPLE WE'RE
GETTING IT TO THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT MOST. FASTNESS
ANATOMIES BACK BUT JUSTICE IN
THIS BUDGET. THE JUSTICE IN
RESILIENCE REQUIRES THAT DATA
REQUIRES THAT ENTERED EPISTEMIC
FORMULA SO ANYWAY MR JEFF
THANKS FOR THE INTELLIGENCE BUT
I THINK YOU'RE ON. I HOPE WE
HOPE WE CAN HOLD ON THIS WILL
HELP DO SOME. WHAT THE END OF
THE I WANT TO. THANK EVERYBODY.
THE MINUTES HERE AT THE IN OF
THE DAY THIS CENTER FOR. IS OF
ONE FIVE BILLION IS A BILLION
DOLLARS FOR CLEAN TRUCKS CLEAN
CARS CAN CLEAN BUSES CLEAN.
AGRICULTURAL EQUIPMENT CLEAN
LIGHT TRUCKS CLEANING DUTIES
AND WE'RE GIVING PEOPLE THE
PEOPLE WHO OWN THESE ARE WANT
TO ON THESE MONEY TO
INCENTIVIZE THEM TO BUY. THESE
HYBRID OR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES SELECTED AT. I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF. THIS IS VERY
LITTLE SPACE IN THE- M. A. R.
MEDIA FOR HER FOR A SENATE
PROPOSAL GIVEN ALL THE ROARING
THAT'S GOING ON ON THE OTHER
SIDE BUT WE GOT. WE THERE IS OF
A BILLION DOLLARS HERE TO GIVE
TO PEOPLE TYPE BY CLEAN
VEHICLES WHICHEVER TYPE OF
VEHICLE WAS UNDER IS IN THERE-
PORTFOLIO SO. LET'S OF OTHER
STUFF HERE OF OTHER- BUT THANK
YOU ALL FOR- YOUR-
PARTICIPATION TODAY AND-
OBVIOUSLY DISCUSSIONS WILL.
WILL CONTINUE WILL MOVE ON TO
THE PUBLIC COMMENT. PERIOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AS A
REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-4185 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS THREE THREE
EIGHT OH FOUR SIX SEVEN. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS. I MAY HAVE TO
INSTITUTE HIGH LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. USUALLY NOT MIGHT
WAY BUT TODAY I'M GOING TO ASK
THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
PROVIDE THEIR COMMENTS. TO
EITHER. IT CAN ADD TO ONE
MINUTE AND ON ANY OF THE I. D.
ONE THROUGH THIRTEEN ARE HE- SO
LET'S BEGIN THE HEARING- ICE NO.
HERE IN REAL THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE- TO TESTIFY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE ONE TWO
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY. OKAY I
DON'T SEE ANY PEOPLE THERE SO
LET'S GO TO THE- MODERATOR IF
YOU'LL PLEASE PROP. THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO LIKE TO
TESTIFY- WE'LL HEAR FROM THE
FIRST. PERSON ON. HOW MANY DO
WE HAVE THANK YOU. PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO NOW. JUST NINETY ONE
AND THEN THE- FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND WE HAVE- TWENTY
FIVE IN Q. WE WILL GO TO THE
FIRST LINE OF FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN I'M GONNA GO TO MY
OFFICE. GOOD MORNING MY-
REMEMBER OF HIS NECK COOPER OF
CAL AGAIN WASTE- CALLING INTO
SOME THE TIME FOR S. B. EIGHTY
THREE THE CASE. AS DIRECTOR
POINT OUR HER- CAL WAS ABOUT AS
YOU LONG TIME OUT COMPANY PLAN
TOO MANY MY EMISSION- FOR SOLID
WASTE CONTRACT OF ORGANIC CHEN.
AND THAT PLAN GOES IN EFFECT
EARLY NAY YEAR- SO LOCAL HAS
BEEN GIVEN A REALLY BIG. IN
TERMS OF EMPLOYMENT THE PROGRAM
INCLUDE- SIGNIFICANT START UP.
THIS YEAR NEXT YEAR TO ABOUT
STATE CON COOPER COVERING HER
TO KEEP ORGANIC WAY OUT OF LINE.
I GIVEN THE ERROR. IN THE
IMPACT OF NAFTA CONNECTION ON.
ALSO HAVE A VERY SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON PINE. BUT WE DO NEED
MORE ONGOING FUNDING FOR
ORGANICS PROCESSING
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE APPRECIATE
THE FOCUS THIS YEAR ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT START UP COSTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE CHAIR
LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE ON
THIS AND OTHER MATTERS NECKS
MEMBER FIVE MODERATOR. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO LINE OF FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO GO AHEAD. GO AHEAD. FORTY
SEVEN. OKAY PRESUMABLY THEY
SUPPORT THE PLAN. MEXICO
CAROLINA SIXTY THREE LINE IS
OPEN. NINE SIX THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YOU HAVE A TIME YOU.
THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREAT THANKS A
LOT MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BILL MCGOVERN WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR AND-
JUST WANTED TO DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE NEEDS IN A
COUPLE OF THE LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS I KNOW
YOU HAVE A LOT OF COMPUTING
NEEDS BUT- IN BOTH THE
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROJECTS.
AND IN MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES NEEDS GO WELL BEYOND
THE AMOUNT THAT VISION IN YOUR
PLAN AND IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME
WHETHER THIS YEAR TOTALS MEAN
THAT THERE WOULD BE NO
ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION NEXT YEAR
SO IF YOU COULD CLEAR THAT UP
THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL BUT
IN THE TRANSPORTATION EQUITY
PROJECTS THESE INCLUDE
FINANCING ASSISTANCE FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLE PURCHASERS.
INCLUDES THE VERY POPULAR CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL SCRAPPED AND
REPLACED PROGRAM- INCLUDES
CREAM MOBILITY OPTIONS AND
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROJECTS WHICH ALLOW
PEOPLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO CLEAN
MOBILITY WITHOUT OWNING
VEHICLES THESE PROJECTS ARE ALL
OVER. THEY'RE ALL EITHER OUT OF.
MONEY FOR WILL BE SOON.
SIMILARLY IN HEAVY DUTY THE AIR
WAS BOARD PRINT THAT THE NEW.
FOR NEXT FISCAL YEAR WOULD BE
UP TO EIGHT HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS AND- IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE ELECTRIFY OUR
HEAVY DUTY TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR AND THESE INCENTIVES ARE
A KEY WAY TO DO THAT AND TO
ADVANCE THE TECHNOLOGY SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU AND
FOR OTHERS ON THE LINE THE
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROGRAM
IS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
TOTAL IT'LL BE SEVENTY FIVE
THIS YEAR SEVENTY FIVE FOR
FISCAL TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
LIKEWISE THE CVR P. PROGRAM. IS
A TWO YEAR ANNUAL IT'S THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION BUT IT'S
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR AND- AND A HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION FOR TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND- THE SENATE IS
COMMITTED TO A THIRD YEAR OF A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
FROM GREENHOUSE GASES IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY.
TWENTY FOUR AND LIKEWISE C. H.
FEB. H. VEB UP PROGRAM FOR-
TRUCKS IS THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION TOTAL IT'S A HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION. THIS YEAR AND
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION FOR
FISCAL TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND
AS WELL AS THE CHORUS FIFTY
MILLION SPLIT UP INTO HERE'S- A
MODERATOR NEXT- PERSON. THANK
YOU WITHOUT A LINE OF FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF LOCAL CONSERVATION CORD BE
SUPPORT THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR EXPANSION OF THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING POP PILOT
PROJECT. THIS WILL PROVIDE
CRITICAL RECYCLING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CRITICALLY
FOR CURRENTLY UNDERSERVED AREAS
OF THE STATE. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE IN THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE IN MY NOTES
WHAT REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT WE SUPPORT B. TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
HEALTHY AND RESILIENT FOREST AS
PART OF THE LARGER WILDFIRE
PENSION PACKAGE. THANK FINALLY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HABITAT CONSERVATION PLANNING
COALITION WE SUPPORT THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR WETLANDS
RESTORATION BUT THERE IS ALSO A
CRITICAL NEED FOR INVESTMENT
AND BROADER NATURAL LANDS
CONSERVATION OF AT LEAST FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
BUDGET COMMITTEES TO ENSURE
THOSE INVESTMENTS. ARE PART OF
THE BUDGET PACKAGE THANK YOU.
THANKS THANK YOU THE NEXT TO GO
TO A LINE OF SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
NATALIE RIVERA ON BEHALF OF
BOTH VALLEY CAN AND CAL DOWN ON
PARTY ISSUES THIRTEEN ON THE
KIND OF CAP AND TRADE SPENDING
PROGRAMS PUSH ON BEHALF OF THAT
WE CAN WE DID WANNA ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR AND TO PRETEND.
PERTAIN TO EQUITY PROGRAM. WE
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT THE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN
FUNDING OVER TWO YEARS
ALLOCATED TO CLEAN CAR STRAW
AND OTHER ACTUALLY PROGRAM.
WELL WE DO ASK THAT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING BE ALLOCATED TO THE
PROGRAM IN ORDER TO MAKE UP FOR
THE LOST FUNDING OVER THE LAST
YEAR AND THAT ANY FUNDING
RECEIVED A FAIRLY AND EQUITABLY
EQUITABLY. DISTRIBUTED AROSS
PROGRAMS. I BEHALF OF CARAVAN
WE ARE THAT FUND FOR OUR-
VANPOOL BE INCLUDED IN THE THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET THROUGH A ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION.
TO HELP FORMER BAND CALLED BUY
MORE VEHICLES CURRENTLY NO
FUNDING IS BEING PROPOSED FOR
THE SERVICES WHICH ON THE FARM
THAT ARE MOST IN NEED
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. WELCOME
NEXT. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO
LINE OF EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS ALEXANDER FROM CAL
START HERE ALSO TO COMMENT ON
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN AND
EXPRESS OUR GENERAL SUPPORT FOR
THE G. CARE ACT PLAN FOR LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION AND THAT
STRATEGY. AND IN PARTICULAR THE
ADDITION ON FUNDING FOR THE T.
V. R. P. AND THE SENATE
PROPOSAL. HOWEVER WE DO WANT TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF OTHERS
THAT THE DEMAND FOR EQUITY AND
CLEAN TRUCK AND BUS PROGRAM
GREATLY EXCEED. EVEN THE
PROPOSED FUNDING ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO FUNDING
LAST YEAR. WE HOPE YOU WILL
FIND THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE
WORTHY OF ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT. AND YOU CONSIDER
THE GENERAL FUND SURPLUS AND
HOW BACK IN THE LATE OUR
ECONOMY AND CREATE HIGH ROAD
JOBS. BUT ALSO ECHO OTHERS
REQUEST FOR CLARIFICATION AFTER
THE ALLOCATIONS FROM THAT YEAR
AFTER THE PRESIDENT FISCAL YEAR
AND FOR TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
WHETHER THIS PLAN MEANS THAT
THERE WOULD NOT BE
APPROPRIATIONS RG GERAK. FOR
THOSE PROGRAMS DURING THE NEXT.
BUDGET CYCLE THANK YOU. MAX
THANK YOU AN EXTRA PHOTO LINE
OF THE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS.
READY WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL OR
NRDC EXTREMELY PLEASED TO SEE
THE SENATE EXPENDITURE PLAN
BECAUSE FINDING FOR THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
WHICH AS YOU ALSO LOOK AT USING
DIRECT HOCKEY IS THE ONLY
PROGRAM OF ITS KIND IN
CALIFORNIA THAT FOCUSES
EXCLUSIVELY ON SERVING LUNCH
AND HELP WITH THE LEARNER
EDUCATION THE UPGRADE BUT
REDUCE EMISSIONS STATE RG AND
IMPORTANTLY SAVE PEOPLE MONEY
ON THEIR UTILITY BILL. IS A
SIZEABLE WAIT LIST FOR THE
PROGRAM TO BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED PROPOSED FUNDING
THAT OFTEN AFTER REGISTER
SUPPORT FROM IRAQ ON BEHALF OF
A CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT FUNDING OR LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION PARTICULARLY
CLEAN CARDS FOR ALL OF THE
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROJECT.
WE'RE ALL WELL AWARE
TRANSPORTATION REPRESENTS THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF EMISSIONS AND
POLLUTION IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ALREADY
BURDENED BY MULTIPLE COLLISIONS
ARE SAYS BUT THE SAME
CLARIFICATION QUESTION OF MR
MCGOVERN AND WITHOUT THE INNER
ABOUT WHETHER THE TO YOUR SPLIT
MEANS THAT THERE WILL BE NO
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THESE
PROGRAMS NEXT YEAR I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THE DETAILS IN THE COMING DAYS.
FINALLY WE APPRECIATE THE
PROPOSED FUNDING FOR HFC
REFRIGERANT AGENCIES ARE AMONG
THE MOST POWERFUL AND FASTEST
GROWING SOURCE CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS IN THE WORLD BUT
THEY DON'T GET A LOT OF
ATTENTION IT COULD BE THOUSANDS
OF TIMES MORE POWERFUL THAN THE
OTHER TWO THEY DO DAMAGE
QUICKLY AND HAVE AN OUTSIZED
IMPACT ON GLOBAL WARMING THANK
YOU FOR CONTINUING TO MOVE THE
BALL FORWARD ON THAT ISSUE
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE CATCHING THAT H. AS A
REFRIGERANT- EXPENDITURE AND
FOR EVERYBODY ON THE LINE FOR
CLARIFICATION. THE PROPOSAL
THIS YEAR IS THIS YEAR IT'S A
IT'S A FLOOR THERE'S NOTHING
YOU KNOW WE WILL SIT BACK AND
LOOK ABOUT ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR NEXTYEAR WE LOOK AT THE
AUCTION RESULTS BUT THIS IS NO
WAY SHOULD BE INTERPRETED AS
PRECLUDING ADDITIONAL MONIES TO
GOING TO- THE CLEAN CAR PROGRAM
SO. THAT WAS A THINK OF IT. AS
A FLOOR. RIGHT NEXT. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LOT OF NAY. THREE A
LINE OF OEN. THANK YOU MR
SHARE THIS IS MARROW. ON BEHALF
OF THE ALL. OF CAT. I WANTED TO
GO AND OUR- FOR THE THIRD
MILLION. THAT WAS PROPOSED BY
THE ADMIN. FOR THE HEALTHY
PROGRAM VERSUS THE TWENTY
MILLION THAT IS PROPOSED BY THE
SENATE. WE'RE ALSO REVIEWING
THAT TEN MILLION DOLLARS A
SENATE IS PROPOSING PROPOSING
FOR. THE MUSEUM REDUCTIONS AND-
AND HOPEFULLY WILL BE
SUPPORTING THAT DOWN THE ROAD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF NINETY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS BRENDAN TO A COMING OUT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION. CALIFORNIA IS
FACING ENORMOUS CHALLENGES IN
MEETING HEALTH BASED AIR
QUALITY ATTAINMENT STANDARDS.
IN REDUCING AIR POLLUTION AND
TOXIC SKIN IN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES SIGNIFICANT
INCENTIVE FUNDING IS CRITICAL
FOR MEETING THE STANDARDS.
XCELERATED NEAR TERM EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS IN IMPROVING PUBLIC
HEALTH MORE QUICKLY ACCORDINGLY
WE APPRECIATE THE INCENTIVE
FUNDING THE SENATE IS PROVIDING
FOR IMPORTANT AIR QUALITY
PROGRAMS. MAINLY THE EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY AIR
PROTECTION PROGRAM FARMER
PROGRAM IN RESIDENTIAL WOOD
SMOKE REDUCTION PROGRAM HOWEVER
SHOULD THE MAILING VISION
CONTAIN A SIGNIFICANT BUDGET
SURPLUS AS ANTICIPATED WE ASK
THAT YOU RE EVALUATE THE
FUNDING LEVELS IN YOUR PLAN.
AND PRIORITIZE FUNDING FOR
THESE IMPORTANT CLEAN AIR
PROGRAMS FURTHERMORE WE
APPRECIATE THE FIFTY MILLION IN
FUNDING FOR LOCAL AIR DISTRICT.
SB SIX SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY ARE
PROTECTION PROGRAM AND
IMPLEMENTATION BUT DO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THIS AMOUNT DOES
NOT COVER CURRENT COSTS
INCURRED. AS A RESULT OF THIS
STATE MANDATED PER. FOR ACCOUNT
FOR COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
TO PROGRAM THANK YOU THAT.
THANK YOU AND NEXT GO TO LINE
UP FIFTY FIVE AIRLINER OPEN.
WINDS FIVE YEAR LINE OF THE YOU
HAVE ASSIGNED ME A- YES HI THIS
IS TO WE HONOR THEM BECAUSE I
OWNERS IS A FEW ACT. PLEASE
SUPPORT THE SENATE PROPOSAL FOR
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
ORGANIC WASTE INTRODUCTION TO
HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
FIREMAN'S SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
SENATE PROPOSAL FOR FUNDING TO
REPLACE DIESEL TRUCKS AND
SEVERAL PEOPLE HAVE COMMENTED
THIS IS A CRITICAL NEED TO TAKE
TO GET I'M NOT PUTTING VEHICLES
OFF THE ROAD AND QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
REITERATE THE COMMENTS MADE BY
SENATOR DOLLY ABOUT THE NEED TO
ALLOCATE FUNDING FOR BIOMASS
UTILIZATION. CALIFORNIA STATE
LAW REQUIRES FOUR IF YOUR
MOBILE AND OTHER VEGETATION
REMOVAL ON. A MILLION ACRES A
YEAR THAT'S GOING TO GENERATE
TEN TO FIFTEEN MILLION BONE DRY
TONS. OF COURSE WASTE AND OTHER
VEGETATION. WE KNOW THAT THAT
MATERIAL CAN BE PUT TO
BENEFICIAL RE USE EITHER AT BIO
ENERGY- AND WHAT PRODUCTS. AND
LYFT CONSERVATIVE BIO ENERGY IT
CUTS PARTICULAR MATTER BLACK.
CARBON AND METHANE NINETY EIGHT
PER. COMPARED TO A AND BURN
THAT'S ACCORDING THE APP CAL
AREA BOARD. BUT WE NEED TO THAT
BY FUEL. IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO GET
IT OF THE FOUR. WELL WE HEARD
NEED TO SHOULD PUT IT TO
PROTECT USE SO. WE THE SENATE
TO ADD. FOR THE- UTILIZATION IN
ADDITION TO THE HELL FOREST ON
THE THANK. THANK YOU NEXT.
THANK YOU MEXICO TELL OF THE-
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI KERRY HOW
CAN MEMBERS SHE ON BECAUSE
ASSOCIATION OF BANKS AND THE
HALF OF ALAMEDA WE GET THE
BANKING BUT WAS STILL VALLEY-
SUPPORT THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR ONE TIME PER POLICY ALL
AND ALIGNING WITH THE ELECT TO
GET WAIT THAT BUT JUST TO THE
FOOD BANK. OBVIOUSLY WORK YOU
MAKE PLAYED ABOUT THE BILL TO
PARTNER WITH THE YOUR THINK AND
JENNA. THEY GET THE AND
CRITICAL GOING LAND FONG ITTO
PEOPLE IN NEED- BUT IT'S EITHER
HAVE ANYTHING EXAMPLES
INCLUDING IN UNDERSERVED AREA
WHERE THINKING OUR THE PAIN
DON'T HAVE THE AND LET ARE
TURNING TO FOOD BANK NOT JUST
TO BE PARTNER IN IN THE BURDEN
PROOF BACK HELP NAY IT AND SO
REALLY CAN BECOME FIRSTHAND
IMPACT OF. WHY THIS ONE TIME
FUND ARE NEEDED AND TO ALL YOU
AFTER THANK THANK YOU NEXT.
THANK YOU AND THAT'S TO GO TO.
OF NINETY THREE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE MARINES AND MARK
STONE OF THE HOUSING PARTNERS
IN YOUR VERY TO THE CHAIR AND
THE SENATE THE RECOGNITION AND
FUNDING FOR THE LOWER INCOME Y.
PROGRAM. THROUGH THE CAP AND
TRADE SPENDING PLAN. LIFEWORK
BRINGS ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND
SOLAR TO THE RESIDENTS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHICH MEETS
THREE KEYS LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES THE PRODUCES
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IT
INCREASES AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND IT ADDRESSES EQUITY
CELEBRATE THANKFUL AND. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ADOPTION OF THE
BUDGET. THANK YOU NEXT. THANK
YOU AND OVER TO A LINE OF
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MORNING MR CARE NUMBER HE'S TOO
LEAN MALACHOWSKI FALL AND THEY
HAVE TO THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION
SEEKING TO ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTEEN. HOW ETP APPRECIATE
THE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT MADE
AND LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION
TO MEET OUR GOALS. MORE THAN A
SINGLE YEAR OF INVESTMENT INTO
CHINA ABSOLUTELY A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION- AND SO WE
APPRECIATE ALSO THE INCLUSION
OF CTRP IN THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL- THAT IS ESSENTIAL TO
MEETING OUR GOAL- WE THINK
THOUGH THAT THAT FINISHING
TOUCHES- TOWARD THE G. CARE ACT
INVESTMENT. REALLY IS NOW
FOCUSED ON THE RE AUTHORIZATION
OF THE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE. WE
CAN FIX YOUR OTHER IMPORTANT TO
LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS BUT A LONG TERM SUCH
AS KARL MOYER IAN THAT HE AND
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION.
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT THE
SENATE IS ON A ROLL AND WE.
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
GROWING THANK YOU. NECKS THANK
YOU AND WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SH YES GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
MICHELLE YOUNG WITH THE COUNTY
OF SANTA CLARA CALLING TO
SUPPORT THE ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
ORGANICS DIVERSION AND CLIMATE
PROTECTION. JUST WANTED TO ADD
COMPONENTS TO THOSE THAT HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN MADE AND REMIND
THE COMMITTEE THAT-
JURISDICTIONS AND COUNTIES LIKE
OURS. HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
HARD TO LEVERAGE OUR RESOURCES
AND WORK TOGETHER TO MAXIMIZE.
THE BENEFITS OF OUR
EXPENDITURES IN ORDER TO LIMIT
THE COST IMPACTS TO OUR RATE
PAYERS AND LOCAL LANDFILLS WHO
WOULD BE- HELPING TO PUT SOME
OF THE BILL. WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK IN THIS WAY IN ORDER TO
MAXIMIZE THE UTILIZATION OF
GRANT FUNDING. AND AND STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE INCLUSION OF THIS
ONE TIME FUNDING OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION AND APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF INCLUDING THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NACS.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE OF
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CATHY FREEMAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. INCLUDE PART OF THE
SENATE THAT THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE ORGANIC WASTE INVESTMENT
I'LL BE BRIEF EVERY COUNTY IS
WORKING HARD TO IMPLEMENT
STATEWIDE AT THE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE CLIMB APARTMENTS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL ACOSTA
IMPLEMENT THESE REQUIREMENTS
HAVE BEEN ESTIMATED AT OVER
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS. AND
WITHOUT SUPPORT FROM THE STATE
THAT WILL FALL IN LARGE PART ON
RATEPAYERS WERE STRUGGLING
DURING THE DIFFICULT TIME.
FINDING WILL GIVE THE BIRTH OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NEED TO
ADVANCE IT'S IMPORTANT SHORT
LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANT FALL ON
TIME WE URGE YOU TO CONTINUE
SUPPORT FOR THE FOR THE ONE
TIME TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ORGANIC WASTE DEVELOPMENT. AND
THANK. YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
ALL OF THEIR WORK ON THAT.
YOU'RE WELCOME THANK YOU I NEXT.
THANK YOU WILL TO LIE OF SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FINALLY
BURNS. IN ORDER CHEN MEMBERS
DOING JACK HERE TO BE HAPPY
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION MY COMMENT IS
REALLY HEARTBEAT ISSUE THIRTEEN
ON THE SPENDING CAP AND TRADE
SPENDING PLAN WE APPRECIATE AND
SUPPORT THE SENATE EMPHASIS ON
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
AND INCLUSIONS TO EUROPEAN
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROGRAMS
IN YOUR SPENDING PROPOSAL WE
WOULD LIKE TO ENSURE THAT THE
SENATE CONSIDERS THE NEED TO
PROVIDE INVESTMENT IN CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT THE
DEPLOYMENT THESE CLEAN VEHICLE.
WE HOPE IS JUDICIAL ALLOCATIONS
MADE TO CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PAKISTANI
CONTINUES TO CONFIGURE GENERAL.
FUND INVESTMENTS THANK YOU.
NEXT THANK YOU OUR NEXT TO GO
TO LINE OF SEVENTEEN LINE IS
OPEN. WIND SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES GOOD MORNING CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD AT
THAT YEAH GOOD MORNING CHAIR.
THE DAVE BRENTON WITH THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS AT CAP STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR
UNDERSERVED FARMERS. AND THE
SECOND CONSCIOUS THREE POINT
THREE FIVE MILLIONTHAT YOU CAN
CLICK. THIS PROGRAM WILL AMONG
OTHER THINGS THAT THE SMALL AND
SOCIAL TO PART SUPPLY PERFECT
FUNDING THAT AS WELL YOU THAT.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE DISMAYED THAT
THIS PROPOSE THAT THE CUT THE
GOVERNOR BUT THIRTY PER SO DOWN
TWENTY NINE. IF YOU KNOW
ANYTHING MORE MONEY TO BE OUT
TO THIS. WHICH IS HOW OVER SAID.
AS ENTER A DROUGHT THERE'S
BETTER JUST WATER THAN IN THIS.
MORE SOIL ORGANIC MATTER NEEDS
MORE WATER RETENTION MEANS LESS
IRRIGATION REQUIRED. WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE FUNDING FOR SWEET
BUT I KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING SIXTY MILLION NOW.
NOT THE FORTY MILLION THE
SENATE IS DISCUSSING. THIS
AGRICULTURAL WATER USE
EFFICIENCY PROGRAM WILL HELP
WITH DROUGHT BUT ALSO WITH THE
IMPACT OF SIGMA AND RURAL AREAS.
FINALLY WE DEPORTED TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ORGANICS DIVERSION FROM
LANDFILLS. WE MADE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTING THESE SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE REQUIREMENTS BUT
WE ARE FAR BEHIND THE SCHEDULE
FOR THE LEGISLATURE CREATED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NECKS. THANK YOU NEXT OVER TO
LINE OF FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU SEE MEDICARE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES THE STATION
THE MOST CRITICAL AIR POLLUTION
CHALLENGES IN THE NATION AND
ACCORDING TO OUR MOST RECENT AT
THE AIRPORT 90% OF CALIFORNIANS
OF AN AREA WITH UNHEALTHY OZONE
AND OR- PARTICLE POLLUTION.
YOURS LEGISLATION APARTHEID THE
STATE'S BENCH COMMITTEE SOMEHOW
IF YOU COULD BUDGET PROCESS
INICIALES INDIVIDUAL ABLE TO
BREATHE CLEAN HEALTHY AIR
QUALITY TRACK ARE KIND OF CRAZY
JUST. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE
BEST A FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
THAT COULD BE A ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM PARKS
ALL THE CORN THE COMPULSION
VISIONS OF YOUR MACHINE VEHICLE
BECAUSE IT RETIREMENT OVER
MONTHLY CARS AND VEHICLES.
MEDICINE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
THE MEDICINE OF A HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION TO EXPLOIT THE
TRANSMISSION OF GERMISTON
TRUCKS AND OFF ROAD EQUIPMENT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO TO BE OF
COURSE IF YOU TO COVER A LARGE
PORTION HARMFUL AIR POLLUTION
AND IT'S OF COURSE IMPACT.
THANK YOU TO THE- FOR THE THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE ABOUT. IN A
SIX. MEDIA PRODUCTIONS PROGRAM
FUNDS FROM THE G. ASKED SUPPORT.
OUT FRANCHISE LOCAL AND- WITH.
YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT. MAX
THANK YOU SOME OF. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MORE TURN MEMBERS ARE
BACK AMERICANS AMERICAN FOR
CHIU HEALTH CRIME IN AFRICA
NETWORK AND THE CAR CYCLE. ON
ISSUE NUMBER WHILE WE SHIP THE
SIX MILLION AND FUND YOUR
VOTING TODAY THE ASK THAT YOU
THE SICK INVESTMENT AND MY THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED IN A STROKE
PACKAGE WHICH SPECIFIC SUPPORT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FARMERS IN
THE STATE CRITICALLY OVER
DRAFTED BASINS ON ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT WE SUPPORT THE SENATE
PROPOSAL TO FIND POWER CYCLE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION FOR ORGANIC
WASTE DIVERSION. ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
FORTY MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
YOU ARE MAKING TODAY WE ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT THE SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND SWEET AND
THE GOVERNOR START PACKAGE
ISSUE TWELVE WE SUPPORT THE
THREE POINT THREE FIVE MILLION
AND TECHNICAL. ASSISTANCE FOR
UNDERSERVED FARMERS. IT NUMBER
THIRTY. WE URGE THIS COMMITTEE
TO MAKE HER A VAST INVESTMENT
IN THE HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM
THE TWENTY MILLION PROPOSED AT
THE NEXT OPPORTUNITY. AND
DOESN'T COME CLOSE TO MEETING
THE FARMERS DEMANDS THIS
PROGRAM IS MUCH OF THE DROUGHT
PROGRAM AS IT IS A CLIMATE
MITIGATION TOOL. WE SUPPORT THE
SENATE OVERALL PROPOSAL TO FIND
METHANE REDUCTION WHICH
INCLUDES THE TEN MILLION. THREE
DOLLARS DRAFT TODAY AS WELL AS
THE FIFTEEN MILLION AB GENERAL
FUND FOR THE ALTERNATIVE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM ON LAST
WEEK'S AGENDA. FINALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CARBON CYCLE
ENSUED I EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR
THE SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS. IN
CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS TO FUND
THE STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY
CLIMATE. READY PROGRAM THANK
YOU SO MUCH. NEXT THANK YOU
NEXT DOOR GO TO LINE OF WELL
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SIR MY COUNTY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS A VIETNAM
ERA BAPTIST CHURCH POINT IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE THIRTEEN THE
SENATE CAMPAIGN TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN. FOUNDED IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN CAMPBELL
CALIFORNIA FIRST ONE IS LEAD BY
TO REVIEW TRAIN STATION
HARDWARE AND SOFTWARE IN NORTH
AMERICA CHARGEPOINT HAS BEEN AN
ACTIVE PARTICIPANT IN ADVANCING
TV THE TV INFRASTRUCTURE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WITHIN
THE SENATE CABIN TRADE MANAGER
PLAN FOR SPORTS THE MULTI YEAR
FUNDING APPROACH THE H. B. A.
P. PROGRAM PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE ADDITIONALLY CHARGE
FOR THE SUPPORT OF LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS AND
ENCOURAGES ANYBODY BUT TO BE
HONEST BE PROVIDED AT THE POINT
OF SALE WHICH WAS STREAMLINED
INSTEAD OF PROPHECIES FOR
CONSUMERS. FINALLY RELATED TO
WORKFORCE TRAINING AND
APPRENTICESHIPS WE ENCOURAGE
THE COMMUNITY CENTER THIS
FUNDING IS MADE AVAILABLE TO A
WIDE RANGE OF RENOVATION SO
THAT WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IS
AVAILABLE TO ALL COMMUNITIES OF
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
SHARKS FOR SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL THAT WILL REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST INTERVIEW
CALLS WE LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TRANSURBAN
PERTINI CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
YOU FOR THEIR GRANTED OPTION
ALLERGIC VEHICLES. THANK YOU.
NEXT THANK YOU AND WE WILL TO
LINE OF NINE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER JERRY REMEMBER
WILL A FULLY SHOP ON THE HIGH
OF THE JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT. SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY HOME TWENTY THE
THIRTY MINUTES WITH THE
BANISHED AND STATE. OF MICHIGAN
CHALLENGES IN MEETING OUR GOAL.
WE DO THE COURTS IN CENTER
FUNDING THE PLANET PLANET
PROVIDER FORM AIR PROGRAMS
INCLUDING AB SEVEN COMMUNITY
AIR PROTECTION PRO. FORMER
PROGRAM. TRANSPORTATION EQUITY
PROGRAMS AND THE OFFICE THE
HEALTH OF PROGRAM. HOWEVER THE
MAY REVISION DOES CONTAIN OR
WILL CONTAIN A SIGNIFICANT
BUDGET SURPLUS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
DISCUSSION ON PRIORITIZING
FUNDING FOR THESE IMPORTANT
MULTI. BENEFIT PROGRAM THANK
YOU. NEXT THANK YOU ABOUT TO
LINE OF ONE YOUR LINER OPEN.
THE MORNING CARE NUMBERS THEIR
DOLPHIN HALF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES WE'RE
SPEAKING TODAY ON ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTEEN WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE INCLUSION OF ONE TIME TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR GRANT.
TO CITIES AND COUNTIES FOR
GAINING WICKS DIVERSION FUNDING
IN THE SENATE CAP AND TRADE
SPENDING PLAN I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND THEIR
STAFF FOR ALL THEIR WORK ON
THIS ITEM. DACULA COMMENTED
DIRECTOR WAGNER CITIES IN THE
WORKING IN COLLABORATION WITH
CAL RECYCLE HAVE MADE GREAT
PROGRESS TOWARDS IMPLEMENTING
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE- ARE
NOT ALL JURISDICTIONS ARE IN
THE SAME PLACE ON THEIR JOURNEY
TOWARDS COMPLIANCE. THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN
WILL GO TOWARDS THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION POLITICIAN COST
NECESSARY TO HAVE ALL CITIES
GET THE SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE PROGRAM UP AND RUNNING
AND DOING SO IN A WAY THAT
WORKS BEST FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THIS FUNDING ALSO
COMES AT A CRITICAL TIME AND
WILL HELP GO TO OFFSET THE COST
TO RATEPAYERS. CITY LOOK
FORWARD TO USING THESE MUCH
NEEDED DOLLARS TOWARDS
ACHIEVING OUR SHARED MAPPING
EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE UP. SEVEN NINE
YOUR LINER OPEN. YES GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE BUT IS CHRIS
CHAVEZ THAT THE POLICIES OF
CULTURE FOR CLEAN AIR- WHERE
WOULD MY COMEDY IT'S SIMILAR TO
MY COLLEAGUES YOUR FOCUS ON
PART B. ISSUE THIRTEEN- BUT I
WANTED ALSO PROVIDE A LITTLE
BIT MORE OF A LOCALIZED
PERSPECTIVE. REGARDING THE
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROGRAMS
WITH REQUESTED FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EACH OF
THESE PROGRAMS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT IN MAKING SURE THAT
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. HAVE
ACCESS TO CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
MANY OF THESE COMMUTER UNDER
THE IMPRESSION THAT THEY HAVE
TO DEAL WITH TWENTY THREE YEAR
OLD CARS- IN NOT BEING ABLE TO
LOOK FOR CLEANER FORMS OF
TRANSPORTATION- THE
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROGRAMS
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT THAT
FOLKS DO YOU HAVE ACCESS. TO
CLEANER MODEL WHICH IS
IMPORTANT FOR THEIR HEALTH AS
WELL TO HELP ADDRESS THE
GENERAL COMMUNITY REGARDING THE
MEAT AND THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY REPLACE PROGRAMS WHICH
WERE AT. EIGHT HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR- GETTING
DIESEL VEHICLES OFF THE ROAD IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT- DIESEL
VEHICLES IN ADDITION TO
CONTRIBUTING TO THE SMOG
PROBLEMS IN CALIFORNIA ALSO
CONTAIN CARSON ALSO EMIT-CARCINOGENIC DIESEL PARTICULATE
MATTER. AND THAT. KEY- THAT
POLLUTED HAS A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AND LOW INCOME EARNERS
PARTICULARLY SIX SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITIES NEAR GOOD TO THE
CORRIDORS AS REPLACING HOSE
VEHICLES WHEN THE VERY POINT IN
MEETING OUR COMMITMENT. TO
BEING EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITIES WELL ACTUALLY WELL
IT WE APPRECIATE AND
UNDERSTAND- THAT THE STAGE IN A
GREAT POSITION BEING ABLE TO
FIND- TRANSPORTATION MAY NEED A
HIGHER LEVEL IT SHOULD BE NOTED
THAT. IN ORDER TO MEET OUR
IRRITATE OR QUALITY STANDARDS-
BILLION TO MORE WE NEED TO BE
INVESTED IN THE SOUTH COAST AND
SAN JOAQUIN BASINS WHICH HAVE
BEEN CHRONICALLY. OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL
CLEAN AIR ACT THANK. YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME NEXT. THANK
YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE OF NAY
FIVE RELY IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
JEREMY PERSONALLY OFF ON THE OF
THE WITH THE STATION RIGHT THE
MARATHON. TOP WEIGHT MUCH OF
REYES MANAGEMENT FORTY ON ISSUE
THIRTEEN. WE ARE JUST SUPPORT
OF THE TWO MILLION HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HELP TRY TO MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS I THINK. THREE
OTHER STRONGLY ENCOURAGE A LOT
TO ALSO CAN. ADDITIONAL FUNDS
TO HELP EIGHT IN DEVELOPING AN
FOR HE COMMANDS MILLIONS OF
TONS OF OUR FALLING TOGETHER
THE BRITISH FROM LAND. AND
RESPECT DOES NOT BELIEVE THAT
TODAY MY BE IN PLACE BY TWENTY
FIVE LOOK FOR WITHIN THE WITH
THE LETTER I'M NOT IN THE YOU
FOR THE LOCAL. ZACKS THANK YOU
WILL GO TO ALLOW FOR YEAR LINE
IS A- DR. ARE MORE MR MEMBER OF
THE MILLER HERE ON THE OF THE-
YEAH WHO IS SPEAKING. AND ITS
ACT DID MULTIPLE. YOU DIVERT
AND BURGEONING FROM THE LAN.
I'M WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE Y. TRYING TO HUNDRED NINE
DOLLAR AD. IN THE- IN ORGAN WAY
TO- WE THINK THEY'RE INVESTMENT
WILL CERTAINLY ENABLE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO IMPLEMENT-
THEIR ORGANIC WASTE RECYCLING
PROGRAMS IN A TIMELY MANNER
WITH THE TIMELY IN. TIMELY BUT
THE PROGRAM ACTUALLY THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE. WE THANK YOU FOR
THE CONSIDERATION OF THIS ITEM.
AND- YOU'RE STRUCK THE PORT.
NEXT THANK YOU FOR HOTEL OF
EIGHT TWO YOUR LINE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHERRINGTON MEMBERS
THIS IS FREDDIE CORONADO I'M A
CONSULTANT FOR THE CBS SO WE
DON'T AN EMPLOYEE OUT THERE
THROUGH THE ENVIRONMENT LEADING
MY COMING INDEPENDENTLY OF MY
EMPLOYERS. I AM CALLING IN
SUPPORT FOR THE BUDGET
ALLOCATION FOR SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE IS BUDGET WOULD
ALLOW MANY SMALL COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE ORGANICS
RECYCLING PROGRAM. BERGEN
DEVELOPMENTS THAT INCLUDE
AVERAGE CAMPAIGN COMPOSTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND FOOD WASTE
PREVENTION. THESE ARE ALSO
GREAT GREEN UP. FOR OUR MEETING.
THANK YOU. NEXT THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
BRIDGET MCKAY ON BEHALF OF
GREEK INCREASE IN SUPPORT OF
THE TWO HUNDRED AND FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS TO ASSIST LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IMPLEMENT SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. OVER THE
CALL BEYOND THE COLOR CYCLE
ESTIMATES SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE WILL COST TWENTY TO FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT
THERE WILL NEED TO BE A ROBUST
FUNDING STRATEGY ALSO INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR ORGANIC
WASTE RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE
THANK YOU. BACKS THANK YOU AND
I WILL GO TO LINE OF EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JOHN KENNEDY
AND WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
I'M HERE TODAY JUST TRONG WITH
SUPPORT AND A CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN WITH RESPECT
TO THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
ALLOCATION FOR LOCAL ORGANIC
WASTE GRANTS. AS YOU HEARD LAST
YEAR TOWER CYCLE ADOPTED THAT
LOFTY REGULATIONS AND LOCALS
ARE WORKING HARD TO DEVELOP THE
LOCAL PROGRAMS ORDINANCES
COLLECTION SYSTEMS AND UPDATE
RATES TO ACHIEVE THESE ORGANIC
WASTE RECYCLING GOALS. THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION AND LOCAL
SYSTEMS GRANTS INCLUDED
ALTHOUGH A LONG WAY TO HELPING
BOTH THOSE DEVELOPING BEGIN
IMPLEMENTATION OF STRONG AND
EFFECTIVE ORGANIC WASTE
RECYCLING PROGRAMS. AS HAS ALSO
BEEN STATED THERE IS STILL
ADDITIONAL NEED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING TO
BECAUSE THE TOTAL EXPECTED
COSTS ARE ON THE ORDER OF
TWENTY TO FORTY BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS. SO WE
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL AND I'D
ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE CONTINUED
ALLOCATION OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ANYWAY. REPORTS HEALTH
IMPROVEMENT WILDFIRE RISK
REDUCTION PROJECTS IN LIGHT OF
SB. EIGHT NINE OH ONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT THANK YOU A
LITTLE DON'T WANT ONE YEAR ONE
OF THE- THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FIVE
TRANSIT AND RAIL AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE. I'M CALLING
TODAY REGARDING PART B. IF YOU
THIRTEEN TIPS PRESS OUR
PRESEASON TO THE SENATE FOR
PROPOSING SIGNIFICANT. MULTI
YEAR FUNDING TRANSITION THAT
THE HEAVY DUTY SECTOR INCLUDING
TRANSIT BUSES DOES YOUR MACHINE
TECHNOLOGY. THE FUNDING
OUTLINED FOR EACH TRIP IN
PARTICULAR IT IS ESSENTIAL TO
REDUCING THE COST OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES FOR CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT AGENCY. WE WOULD ECHO
HOWEVER THE COMMENTS MADE BY
OTHER ADVOCATE TODAY THAT EACH
SCRIPT IS ROUTINELY
OVERSUBSCRIBED. I THAT CAN
RESULT IN STAGGERING
WEIGHTLESS. SO YOU CONTINUE
CONSIDER INVESTMENT IN A TRIP
THE LEGISLATURE MAY CONSIDER
PROPOSING TO ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO THAT PROGRAMME.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO URGE
YOU TO CREATE FUNDING SET ASIDE
FOR THE DEPLOYMENT OF ZERO
EMISSION BUSES BY TRANSIT
AGENCIES PACIFIC LEE ACCEPTED
THE FIRST COME FIRST SERVE
PROGRAM. WELL THAT'S STRUCTURES
GRATEFUL BEING EFFICIENT IT
DOES THAT TIMES. PUBLIC
AGENCIES THAT HAVE PROTRACTED.
PROCUREMENT PROPHECIES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. THANK YOU
ORDER LINE- A ONE OH YEAR OF
THE- GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
BIRTH NAME ALL WHILE ON BEHALF
OF ECOLOGY AND SUPPORT AT THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION PARK
ANTIQUATED DIVERSION. THAT PORT
BY THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE AND
SHE THIRTEEN WE WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR INCLUDING THE FUNDING
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THE IMPORTANT
ISSUE AS WE NOW CAO RECYCLED
ADMITTED- PETER INFRASTRUCTURE
COSTS IN THE BILLIONS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. NEXT THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE OVER ONE OH
NINE LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR LOUIS
BROWN ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
FAIRS ASSOCIATION TODAY CALLING
ON ISSUE NINE. THANK YOU FOR
THE COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION
TO DELETE THE TERM STATE
AFFILIATED FROM- THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND MAKE SURE THAT
THAT FUNDING IS AVAILABLE TO
ALL PLAYERS I WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA THEIR NETWORK. ON
ISSUE THIRTEEN ON BEHALF OF THE
NUMBER OF OUR AGRICULTURAL
CLIENTS- HAPPY TO SEE THAT THE
ITEM IS TO REMAIN OPEN WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION WHAT WE DO
APPRECIATE THE SENATE INCLUDING
A HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN. THE AG FUNDING
PACKAGE FOR THE FORMER PROGRAM
WITH ADDITIONAL REVENUES COMING
IN THE STATE LIKE TO WORK WITH
YOU AND THE ADMINISTRATION ON
ADDITIONAL MONIES FOR THAT
FORMER PROGRAM AS WE DO KNOW
THE SUCCESS THAT IT BRINGS IN
REDUCING. CARBON GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND PROVIDING FOR
CLEANER AIR ENVIRONMENT
THROUGHOUT THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AND THE ENTIRE STATE SO
THANK YOU LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU HAVE A GOOD
DAY. THANK YOU NECKS. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE A ONE ELEVEN
pMR CHAIRMAN THE COMMITTEE JOHN
MOFFETT- COUPLE ITEMS ON THE
CAP ON BEHALF OF THE COUPLE
DIFFERENT CLIENTS- FIRST ON THE
ISSUE THIRTEEN FOR THE ALLIANCE
FOR AUTOMOTIVE INNOVATION LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FUNDING
INCLUDED IN THE SENATE PACKAGE
FOR THE CLEAN POWER STROKE. FOR
ALL PROGRAMS AS WELL AS THE
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAMS
BOTH PROGRAMS ARE VITALLY
IMPORTANT. FEATURE ON THIS
VEHICLE ALSO AN ISSUE THIRTEEN
ON BEHALF OF WASTE MANAGEMENT
BOARD TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ORGANIC WASTE RECYCLING
AND DIVERSION INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THEN LASTLY ON BEHALF OF
THE LOCAL NEWS YOUR SCALPEL
WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. THIS IS GAME
OF GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM LOCAL ASSISTANCE GRANT
AND ALSO OUR SUPPORT FOR
FUNDING FOR THE FORMER PROGRAMS
ON BOTH OF THOSE ITEMS- ONE
REFLECTED THE COMMENTS MADE BY
MR BROWN WITH RESPECT TO-
LOOKING FOR OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR BOTH OF
THOSE. IN THE BUDGET PROCESS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ZACKS.
THANK YOU NEXT GO TO LAW OF.
TEN YOUR LINE IS. THIS IS A
TREMENDOUS JOB MALONEY ON
BEHALF OF THE K. COMPOST. IS
SUPPORT OF THE TROOPS MILLION
FOR THE GUY DIVER. I'M TWENTY
MILLION HEALTHY SOIL THOSE OF
START. WE'D LIKE TO SEE MORE
EVERYBODY WOULD ENSURE. ALSO IN
THE HEART OF THE YEAR. BUILDING
TOWN. REMAINING LOS ANGELIDES
WE STRONGLY SUPPORTS- THE HOME
HARDENING PROPOSAL CAST AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD BE
BUILDING BRINGING AND FIREWISE
IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU NEXT.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF ONE OH EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING CARE OR
THAT HE AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY COMBAT ADAM HOBBIT
YOU'RE ON BEHALF OF YOU TO GO.
INTO ISSUE THIRTEEN PART B. ET
GO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INCREASE FUNDING FOR IN
TRANSPORTATION CENTER.
INCLUDING C. B. R. P. AND GREEN
CARDS FOR ALL AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT- MULTI YEAR
INVESTMENT PLAN APPROACH- WE
ALSO EXPRESSED THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN INVESTMENT
BANKING TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT FUTURE OUR- INVESTMENT.
ALL RIGHT NOW IS REALLY THE
TIME TO DOUBLE DOWN BOTH ON
VEHICLE IMPRINTED. AND CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU YOU
REALLY NEED OUR HIGHLY
INTRANSIGENT I THINK IT'S A
GREAT STEP IN THAT DIRECTION-
WE ALSO ECHOED THE COMMENTS
THAT OTHERS IN. THE NEED FOR
ALL THESE INVESTMENTS TO REALLY
HAVE AN EQUITY LINE AS WELL IN
ORDER FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY- PRIOR TO
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR I TRULY EXPERIENCED THE
BENEFITS THEY'RE BUILT. THANK
YOU- AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING BEING A GOOD PARTNER
THANK. THANK YOU NEXT. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE A ONE TWELVE
pMEMBERS OF THE- STAFF MARK
PRAYER ON BY OF REPUBLICS. WE
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND ALL
THOSE WHO ARE INVOLVED IN
DEVELOPING THIS PLAN. IN
PARTICULAR WE WANT TO SUPPORT
THE H. V. I. P. FUNDING SUPPORT
FOR CONVERSION OF SOLID WASTE
AND RECYCLING HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES TWO ZERO AND NEAR ZERO
TRUCKS. IN ADDITION WE WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATIONS TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO HELP EXPEDITE
THE LOCAL CONTRACTING PROCESS.
FOR SENATE BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION WE
ALSO ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDER ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
PERFORMANCE BASED FUNDING
MECHANISMS TO ENCOURAGE. AND
THE EXPANSION AND DEVELOPMENT
OF ORGANICS PROCESSING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL BE
NEEDED TO SUCCESSFULLY ACHIEVE
THE S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
GOALS. CARE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU NECKS.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF
ONE OH SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR LIKE HOW CAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS WILLIAM MARTIN WITH THE
CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY
CALLING ABOUT PARTY ISSUE
THIRTEEN. WE'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OUR GENERAL SUPPORT FOR THE
PROPOSED FUNDING ACROSS THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
INCLUDING EQUITY AND MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY PROGRAMS. AND
PARTICULARLY LIKE WITH THANK
THE SENATE FOR THE PROPOSED.
PRETTY CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROJECT- CTRP. ALLOCATING A
LARGE INVESTMENT WE ARE KEY FOR
THE NEXT THREE YEARS THE
POSITIVE THINKING ALL THAT
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITTED IN OUR
MISSION PUPIL CALLED. ENSURE
THE STATE WILL TRULY TRANSFORM.
THE QUEEN TRANSPORTATION MARKET.
YEAH P. THE NATIONAL OF
REACHING. PER OF NEW VEHICLES.
IS THERE A MEASURE VEHICLE
REQUIRED EVEN MORE FUNDING THAN
PROPOSED ONE. SEVENTY FIVE NOW
PRE. AND LOOKING AT NEEDED
BUDGET SURPLUS CAN HELP. IT'S
CRUCIAL TO THE COURT PROGRAM
THAT HELP LOOK LIKE THAT I'LL
COP. WITH A FOCUS ON EQUITY
HEALTH REDUCE AIR POLLUTION
ACROSS THE STATE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THEIR
MISSION VEHICLE TO DATE AND FOR
YOUR QUESTION THAT YOU'RE
HAVING. TO KEEP YOUR FEET.
WELCOME NEXT. MEXICO ALAINA ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CAN ANYONE HEAR ME. YES
I CAN GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS NATALIE AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO REVIEW THE
AGENDA FOR TODAY AND ISSUES
PRESENTED DURING TODAY'S
HEARING WE WANT THANK YOUNG
VIRGINITY ELEVATES YOU POINT AS
NOTED LAST WEEK WE APPRECIATE
THE SENATE I'M GOING TO WORK
FOR SAFE DRINKING WATER AND ARE
COMMITTED TO CONVERSATIONS
ENSURING THAT THE STATE EFFORT
WILL DRINKING WATER FUNDS
REMAIN FULLY FUNDED. WE HAVE
ENGAGED IN THE AB ONE THOUSAND
PROCESS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND HAVE IDENTIFIED SEVERAL
AREAS RIGHT FOR PROGRAM
IMPROVEMENT INCLUDING. AND MOST
URGENTLY THIRTY. EVERY MONTH
INCLUDE RECKLESS TOLD RESULT
DIRECT MEASURABLE AND
SIGNIFICANT EMISSION REDUCTIONS
FROM POLLUTION SOURCES. THERE
NEEDS TO BE TRANSPARENCY ASK
YOU HOW YOUR DISTRICTS ARE
EXPAN EXPENDING FUNDS FOR BOTH
PROGRAMS ADMINISTRATION AND
INCENTIVES AND CLEAR DIRECTIONS
THAT. THAT THE F. B. HAVE
ULTIMATE AUTHORITY TO APPROVE
EMISSION REDUCTION MEASURES.
ADDITIONALLY ON THE TEN MILLION
METHANE REDUCTION ITEM UNDER
THE HE G. R. S. WE STRONGLY
URGE THE SENATE TO CLARIFY THAT
THIS FUNDING WILL NOT SUPPORT
BUDGET EACH FOR DAIRY BY
DOCTORS. WHICH PERPETUATE AND
EXACERBATE LOCAL POLLUTION IN
COMMUNITIES NEAR DAIRY AND
FURTHER ENTRENCH NATURAL GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE A TIME WHEN THE
STATE MUST BE SHIFTING TO ZERO
EMISSIONS ENERGY. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY COMMENTED AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
ENGAGEMENT IN THIS. PRACTICE
THANK YOU NECKS. THANK YOU OVER
A LINE OF FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME TO
SEPARATE CATHOLIC AND FAR- ON.
AND WHERE THEY STATE'S ONLY NGO
ATTAC COMPLICATED STATUS WITH
THE INTERNATIONAL MARITIME
ORGANIZATION WHICH THAT'S A
GLOBAL SHIPPING LAW. I'M
CALLING TO SPEAK ON ISSUE
THIRTEEN. WE ARE SUPPORT OF THE
FUNDING PROPOSED FOR CARBON
JUST WANTED TO FLAG THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
TREATED TRANSITION CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR DOES
INCLUDE. OFF ROAD VEHICLES
WHICH- DOES INCLUDE SHIPPING
VESSELS IN THE DEFINITION IN
RIGHT NOW MAJOR SHIPPING
COMPANIES ARE MAKING RECORD
PROFIT AS A RESULT OF COULD
REALLY TO CONSUMER SPENDING.
THAT HAS LED TO UNPRECEDENTED
PORT CONGESTION IN THE SAN
PEDRO PORTS WHICH ALSO MEANS I
CAN SHIP POLLUTION. AND THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT NOW PROTECT
OCEAN GOING VESSELS ACCOUNT FOR
A MAJORITY OF THE SMOG FORMING
KNOCKS EMISSIONS IN THEIR AIR
BASE IN BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
AND ON THE CLIMB INSIDE SHOULD
ACCOUNT FOR NEARLY 1% OF THE
COMPANY'S GREENHOUSE GAS
POLLUTION ARE CURRENTLY
CALCULATED. AND I'M I'M SURE
YOU'RE AWARE CALIFORNIA IS
CONSIDERING A NEW CLEAN TWO
ZERO EMISSION RULES FOR
COMMERCIAL HOVERCRAFT VESSELS
WHICH ARE THE SMALL SHIP.
FUNDING IS NEEDED FOR THE
COMMERCIALIZATION OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND FUNDING FOR
SHORE SIDE POWER PLAY AGAINST.
YOU CONSIDER THE GENERAL FUND
SURPLUS WE WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
IN THE DISCUSSION CAN NOT WE
ABOUT THE SHIPPING INDUSTRY'S
IMPACT AND CONSIDER SPECIFIC
FONTS AMERICANS BUT THE PROGRAM
FOR CARDS SHE TRANSITION
SHIFTED YOUR MISSION AND
ELECTRIFIED IMPORTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NECKS NEXT THE LINE
OF. ONE OLD YOUR OF THOUGHT.
BLIND ALSO DO YOU HAVE A TIME
YOU. GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS ANGELA IDR MAYOR CITY
OF MILLBRAE WHICH IS WEST OF
SFO AIRPORT. AND THE FUTURE
HIGH SPEED RAIL STATION IN FACT
THE ONLY STATION BETWEEN SAN
FRANCISCO AND SANTA FE I'M
ACTUALLY SPEAKING ON FOUR
TOPICS TODAY. A NUMBER ONE
GOALIE IN SUPPORT OF THE MONEY
GOING FOR IMPLEMENTING THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE I WORK IN THE
RECYCLING FIELD FOR OVER THIRTY
FIVE YEARS. WITHOUT COMPOSTING
OPERATION SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
ESSENTIAL AND CRITICAL GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE NUMBER TWO I
HAVE A QUESTION ON THE EQUITY
PROGRAMS- BEING NEXT TO THE
AIRPORT WE ARE SUBJECTED TO
NOISE AND A GREAT DEAL OF MICRO
PARTICULATE POLLUTION. WHICH IS
NOT MONITORED BY CARD- AND WE
ARE ALSO NOW WITH FIRES AND
CHANGING WIND PATTERNS GETTING
MUCH MORE AIR POLLUTION ON A
SEASONAL BASIS WE'RE ALSO
LOCATED. BETWEEN TWO FREEWAYS.
OF CAMINO RIEL AND THREE
TRAINED. AND OUR UNIQUE
GEOGRAPHY OF CONCENTRATING AIR
POLLUTION AND NOISE POLLUTION.
ALONG OUR ENTIRE LENGTH AND YET
WE ARE NOT CONSIDERED A
COMMUNITY OF CONCERN SO I FULLY
SUPPORT THE EQUITY PROGRAMS.
BUT IT CONCERNS ME THAT. IN
UNITY IS LIKE MINE CANNOT GET
THE ASSISTANCE WE NEED TO
PROTECT OUR RESIDENTS. THAT
SAID I CHAIR THE SFO NOISE
ROUNDTABLES GROUND BASED IN
WAYS COMMITTEE WE'VE DONE
RECENT RESEARCH ON NATURAL
SOLUTIONS TO NOISE AND AIR
POLLUTION AND IN THAT CASE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE OR STRONGLY
SUPPORTS URBAN GREENING
COMPONENT OF THIS ALTHOUGH THE
MONEY IS GROSSLY INADEQUATE.
TREES IT SOUNDS REALLY WEIRD
CAN HANDLE A LOT OF NOISE A LOT
OF LOW FREQUENCY NOISE FROM
FREEWAYS FROM AIRPORT AND I
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE SENATE TO
PUT MORE MONEY INTO THAT. AND
FINALLY CHAIR I KNOW YOU WANTED
US ALL TO BE HAPPY BUT I HAVE A
HIGH SPEED RAIL. STATION I HAVE
TO REPORT THAT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN HIGH SPEED RAIL CAME
TO MY COMMUNITY AND SAID WE'RE
GOING TO EMINENT DOMAIN A HUGE
PORTION OF OUR LAND RIGHT NEXT
TO THE TRAIN STATION AND TURN
IT INTO A SURFACE PARKING LOT.
THAT KILLED FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT UNITS OF HOUSING
15% AFFORDABLE AND A COMMERCIAL
BUILDING IN THE THREE YEARS
SINCE MY STAFF IS CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL TO
COME UP WITH ALTERNATIVES NO
ALL AT THE END A HIGH SPEED
GROWTH SAYS NO. THE VOTERS WERE
SOLD AT MILLBRAE STATION WOULD
BE UNDERGROUND MEMORIES NOT
ANTI HIGH SPEED RAIL BUT I HOPE
WHEN YOU CONSIDER FUNDING THEM
ESPECIALLY USING CAP AND TRADE
YOU DON'T TURN IT INTO A HEAT
ISLAND SURFACE PARKING LOT. AND
IF YOU SUPPORT THE
UNDERGROUNDING OF MILLBRAE
TRAIN STATION ABBOTT WAS
PROMISED THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL THAT YOU DO. THANK
YOU NECKS. THANK YOU EXTRA
BOTTLE OF ONE THIRD. YEAR ARE.
GO AHEAD ONE THIRTEEN ONE
THIRTEEN AIRLINES. DO YOU HAVE
A TIME YOU. OKAY AND WE WILL
MOVE ON. TO LINE ONE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MENTIONED
WITH WHERE A MODEL WITH CONDOMS
CENTER A NONPROFIT FOCUSED ON
ACHIEVING DECARBONISATION
PATHWAY IN THAT SCALE. CHECKING
ON AN ISSUE THAT ISN'T TIED TO
A SPECIFIC AGENDA ITEM BUT IS
RELEVANT TO EACH DAY AND A LOT
OF THE RECORD BUDGET SURPLUS
THE CARPETS ARE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGED THAT ALLOCATE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
pPERCENT DECLINE. IN RECENT
BUDGET YEARS OKAY TO THE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TOWARDS OUR COMMUNITY
OUR AGENCY THAT HAS LARGELY
GOING TOWARD THE PERSON HE
DIESEL GENERATORS. MOVING
FORWARD WE ARE SUSPECT THE
STATE TO HELP LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS BEGAN PLANNING
FOR GREAT OUT OF USE DUE TO THE
UTILIZATION CLEAN DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCE THAT. EVEN
LOCAL CONTROL OVER HURTING
INCITING IT ONLY MAKES SENSE
HAVE OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
LEVY PLANNING EFFORTS. WHILE
THE STATE POLICY FRAMEWORK
DOESN'T OFFICIALLY CURRENTLY
EXIST SB NINETY NINE BY SENATOR
DOG. WHICH CURRENTLY MAKING ITS
WAY THROUGH THE POLICY PROCESS
WOULD PROVIDE ONE. HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO BE
USED TO PROVIDE FUNDING NEEDED
TO MAKE THAT PROGRAM A REALITY
THE PROVIDED MORE DETAILS IN
THE LETTER THAT WAS UNITS
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU UNEX.
THANK YOU NEXT GO TO LINE A ONE
A- YEAR LINE OF OPEN. WHAT
INSURANCE COMMITTEE MORE OF
SECOND NUMBER. THIS IS TO LOOK
FROM SOUTH COAST CAN DO. CELL
COUNTRY FACING ENORMOUS
CHALLENGES AND REDUCE AIR
POLLUTION TOXICS TO PROTECT
HEALTH ESPECIALLY WITH THAT
MANY BASH ME. EACH ONE OF SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR IN EIGHTY
SIX AND A POINT FUNDING FOR
INDUSTRY. HOWEVER WITH THE AND
SIGNIFICANT ARE. WE ASK THAT
YOU IN THE LEVEL IN YOUR CLASS
TO FOR THE PRIOR TO FUNDING FOR
THIS AND CLEAN PROGRAM. IF YOU
CONSISTING OF INSTANCE FUNDING
CRITICAL HELL THINGS AIR
POLLUTION. EXHILARATING HERE TO
MATURE OPTIONS AND IMPROVING
PUBLIC HEALTH. SOUTH COAST IS
FACING LOOMING FEDERAL
DEADLINES AIR POLLUTION AND
IT'S NOT THAT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN SANCTIONS
RESTRICTIONS ON BUSINESS AND
IT'LL TAKE OVER COULD OCCUR. WE
ALSO APPRECIATE FIFTEEN MILLION
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING FOR AIDS
RESEARCH BUT AS OF NOW DOES NOT
COVER CURRENT POSH CREATED BY
THE STATE MANDATED PROGRAM.
COMMUNITIES ARE ADDED TO THIS
PROGRAM EACH YEAR REQUIRING
INCREASED AND SUSTAINABLE
RESOURCES THE FUNDING IS
CRITICAL TO PROTECT.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU. X. THANK YOU AND THAT LINE
OF FORTY YEAR IS OPEN. HI
RICHARD MILLER I MEAN I KNOW A
LOT OF MYSELF I AM HERE TO TALK
ABOUT. IN THIRTEEN CAPTAIN.
PROGRAM WELL WE'RE PRETTY THE-
SENATE PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE THE
WETLANDS AND ACTUAL WORKING
LANDS AND PART OF THIS YEAR'S-
WE WOULD BE REMISS IN THE US-
NOT NOTE IT. IS NOW TEN MILLION
DOLLARS WILD ABOUT IT
APPRECIATE IT IS- LEE LESS.
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WE HAD
CLEAN IN. THE FIRST YEARS THAT
THE PROGRAM UNFUNDED ADDITIONAL
WE ARE WE WOULD LIKE TO HE WAS
GIVEN THAT THEY HAD. RECORD
SURPLUSES. NO MONEY INVESTED
NOT REACHED J. AND WE WOULD THE
CONVERSE WITH MANY. DEVELOP A
ROLE PLANNED- FUND ACTUALLY
AFTER HERE IN THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE A ONE NINE YEAR
LINE OF THE- GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS REBEL
MONSTER TO NOT- WITH THE TRUST
FOR PUBLIC LAND. PAN AM I'LL
PREFACE THIS BY SAYING I WANT
TO SAY THIS WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT BUT I DON'T. THINK THAT
THE SENATE PROPOSAL
ACKNOWLEDGES. WHAT SCIENCE IS
TELLING US ABOUT THE REALITY IF
YOU. I'M NOT GONNA HALF AND
IT'S IMMEDIATE THREAT ON LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES- THERE'S
ONLY FIVE. MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE URBAN GREENING PROGRAM- IN
THE BACKDROP OF THE HOTTEST
YEAR ON RECORD LAST YEAR THE
HOBBIT. AUGUST THROUGH OCTOBER
IN CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY A
HUNDRED AND 50 DEGREES
TEMPERATURE SURFACE
TEMPERATURES IN PLACES LIKE TO
CLIMB OUT. AND THE REALITY THAT
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T HAVE AIR
CONDITIONING AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE. YOU KNOW
WHETHER IT'S NATION TO EVEN-
KEEP THE HEAT OUT AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS. AND NOT
HAVE BEEN TREE CANOPY AND OPEN
GREEN SPACES AT THE REALLY
DANGEROUS- SITUATION AND I
DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S BUDGET
KNOWLEDGE OF THAT- I URGE YOU
SO. ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
BUDGET SURPLUS BUT- PEOPLE ARE.
SPEAKING TO YOU ABOUT SOME ARE
SAYING IS SEVENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS BUT THIS NUMBER SHOULD
BE IN THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
AND IT STILL WON'T APPROACH THE
NEED. HOW WE CAN REDUCE OUR
EMISSIONS AS MUCH AS WE CAN-
BUT THAT'S NOT GONNA DO
ANYTHING THE HEAT IMPACT BUT AT
THE USISL LOW INCOME COMMUNITY.
ARE IN THE CROSSHAIRS UP. SO I-
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO BE PICKED
BUT- IT BE DIRECTED BY CLIENTS-
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE BE
DIRECTED BY SCIENCE WHEN IT
COMES TO THE- A MEDIA. WRAPPED
UP HE- AND- ARE RE EXAMINE THE
NUMBERS TO URBAN FORESTRY AND
URBAN GRANT. THANK YOU. NEXT
THANK NEXT TO GO TO A UP FOR
SEVEN YEAH IS OPEN. ONE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
MICHAEL BOOKER DOOR WITH
AGRICULTURE ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION ONE OF BRING TO
IMPORT REPORTS TO THE BEACH-
THE FUNDING ALLOCATIONS FOR
EACH YEAR- AND ONE IS THE- AND
METHANE ASSESSMENT THAT CAME
OUT LAST WEEK. WE CONFIRMING
THE VALUE OF AND NEED FOR
CONTINUING TO REDUCE METHANE TO
HELP MITIGATE A LONG TERM
HARMFUL CARBON DIOXIDE
HUMILIATION IN THE GLOBAL
ENVIRONMENT. THE SECOND REPORT
WAS STAGED TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CLIME INVESTMENT FOR. WHICH
AGAIN SHOWED THAT THE DERRY
DIGESTA RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM IS MOST
COST EFFECTIVE AT NINE DOLLARS
A TON AND THE MOST PRODUCTIVE
OVERALL IN TERMS OF GHG
REDUCTION. BEING A TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THAT PROGRAM INTO
EACH YEAR UP TO FIFTY MILLION-
PUTERI METHANE REDUCTION IN THE
GENERAL FUND IS A GOOD START
ALL FOR ALL. HE FALLS FAR SHORT
OF THE NEED AND DEMAND FOR THIS
PROGRAM IN THE SHORT TERM THE
U. N. REPORT POINTED OUT THAT
THIS NEEDS TO BE DONE BY TWENTY
THIRTY. AND THE ONLY WAY THE
STATE'S GOING TO ACHIEVE THE
40% REDUCTION IN DAIRY METHANE.
SEEKING IS TO CONTINUE TO FUND
THIS IMPORTANT PROGRAM. THANK
YOU. NEXT. THANK YOU AND THE
OUR LAST ONE FUEL COMES FROM R.
ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CALLING THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA RESEARCH
RECOVERY INSPECTED. AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL OFFICER FOR THE
CITY OF OCEANSIDE- THANK YOU
FOR TAKING OUR CALL ME YOUR NAY
I'M BREAKING MY SUPPORT FOR THE
ONE TIME FINDING A FEW HUNDRED
MILLION PER IMPLEMENTATION THAT
THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
JURISDICTION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZE THE
NECESSITY TO IMPLEMENT ORGANIC
MANAGEMENT ANDRETRAIN CREAM
STATE WIDE TO ENSURE GREEN HER
GAP MEASURE REDUCTIONS AND ADDS
THAT SHE HAD TAKEN SIGNIFICANT
ACTION TO ADDRESS ORGANIC OVER
THE PAST DECADE. THE FIGHT
LEADERSHIP TO DIVERT ORGANIC
ORGANIC ACROSS CALIFORNIA SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE BILL WILL
INCREASE COSTS SIGNIFICANTLY
AND THEN BILLIONS IN FACT BUT
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY BEING
BORN ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
RATE PAYERS. MANY ANYTHING
RIGHT THE SUFFERING RIGHT NOW
AND IF BUDGET ITEM WILL BE AN
ESSENTIAL PATENTS ACCORDINGLY
ON GOING EFFORTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE I ALSO URGE THAT SHARING
COMMITTEE PROVIDE KERN FUNDING
THAT WILL SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION BY JURISDICTIONS
OF THE STATE REQUIRED PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS ENHANCE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT INNOVATIVE IN CRITICAL
OPERATE IN ORGANIC PROCESSING
WASTE PREVENTION AND RECOVERY
INITIATIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND THAT WILL CONCLUDE OUR
PUBLIC HEARING WAS BRING IT
BACK TO THE DAY S. WE HAVE
SOME- VOTE ONLY MATTERS AC
CENTER STERN AND CENTER DOLLY
AND SEND REQUIRE- WITH US SO IF
WE CAN MOVE TO PART B. OF OUR
CALENDAR WE HAVE VOTE ONLY. AND
CHERYL ENTERTAIN A MOTION- AND
TO PASS. ON ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
THIRTY ONE A PART A ISSUE NOW
ONE. OF RIGHT ARE YOU THAT
NUMBER THREE THAT TO. WE'RE
GONNA DO. TO SO THIS IS JUST
PART EIGHT ISSUE NUMBER ONE
THERE'S MOTION BY SENATE
MCGUIRE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MY CASKEY HI MY CASKEY I DALY.
DALY AYE MCGUIRE RIGHT I STERN.
STERN AYE AND ZERO THERE'S FOUR
ZERO THE MOTION IS APPROVED NOW
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
ISSUES NUMBER AND PART A ISSUES.
FIRE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHY
CASKEY AYE AYE CASKEY AYE DALY
KELLY NO MCGUIRE ACQUIRE I'M
STERN. STERN AYE- NINE CLOSE
ROLE TELLING VOTES IT'S THREE
ONE THE ICE HAPPEN NOW MOVE TO
PART B. DO WE HAVE A MOTION WE
HAVE A MOTION ON. ISSUES NUMBER
ONE TWO AND THREE ISSUES SIX
AND SEVEN AND ISSUES NINE TEN
ELEVEN. CENTER DOLLARS A MOTION
THERE'S A MOTION BY CENTER
DOLLY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
ISSUES ONE TWO AND THREE SIX
AND SEVEN NINE TEN ELEVEN. MY
CASKEY HI MY TASK I DALY DALLI
I REQUIRE REQUIRE I STERN.
YOU'RE A CLOSER TALLY THE VOTES.
FOR IS ZERO THE ICE HAVE IT NOW
WILL HAVE AND A MOTION JUST
ISSUING EIGHT. THANK YOU SAN
REQUIRE MOVE FISHING EIGHT.
SHORTLY CALL THE MAN. AYE
CASKEY MY AYE DOWN NO NOW I
KNOW CHOIR REQUIRE HIGH. HI. ON
PART B. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WIECKOWSKI HI I. CASKEY VALLEY.
DALY NOT MILLION MCGUIRE RIGHT
REQUIRE ICE. I CLOSE ROLE
TELEVOTES THREE ZERO IT'S- THE
MATTER IS THE MANAGER PROOF IS
SECOND TODAY CAL- WE HAD
MATTERS THAT WE TOOK OFF TODAY
WE ARE PUTTING TOGETHER NEXT
TO. AGENDA AND WE HAVE THE A
LETTER IN A WORD FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BEING CA WITH
MEMBERS OF THE AND- MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE BUT- BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER TWO IS THAT WOULD TURN.
BOB.